let me go back and watch these following
documentaries about people who really
took an unorthodox path okay and then
let me sit down and ask why do I feel
like I
am compelled to
rush
so there you have it wo that was one
that was [__] fire thanks this has
been on my mind non-stop for the last
couple of
[Music]
months
no Ken Tim Ferris it's been a minute
nice to see you it's great to see you it
really is our last
Rio from an audio perspective was ages
ago number
75 on the podcast now close to 700
episodes wow yeah and at that time it
was how Facebook's number 30 employee
quickly built four businesses and gained
40 lbs with weight training I feel like
my headlines have deteriorated over time
they
become very s of pedantic and pedestrian
and descriptive that is better copy so I
need to I need to work on that copy
maybe you drafted that copy yourself
actually for all I know that could have
been the case we have a lot to talk
about but for people who don't have any
context yeah man could you give a little
self inro great to see you first off
yeah great to see you now we're at $8
million businesses which is pretty
amazing I was number 30 at Facebook
number four at mint.com I was a cubicle
monkey at Intel for a very brief moment
which sucked which led me to this
entrepreneurship journey and then I've
started so many different businesses
that failed some worked and now I I
helped run apps.com number one side
online for software deals we do about
$80 million a year which is unreal it
started bootstrapped in a weekend I
couldn't believe it when I saw that I
can't believe it I remember day one of
appsumo effectively back in the day it's
been crazy and you were big help with it
you're super big help with getting it
going so thank you you're welcome
YouTube channel has done pretty well
million Subs got a book million dollar
weekend coming out to help people you
know very similar complimentary to for
our work week M and we're here today
let's do a
little trip down memory lane because
ages ago
2011 right so this is going back ways
we've known each other a long time I
remember we first met I want to say at a
coffee shop in Mountain View California
on Castro aot has transpired since we're
going to cover quite a bit of it and get
into a lot of tactics in this
conversation Noah always is able to
deliver specifics concrete recommended
actions scripts you name it so we're
going to get into all that juicy stuff
but you had a guest blog post on my blog
in
2011 and it's easy for me to forget it's
easy for some people to forget or just
not realize that the blog for me was
really the connective tissue that
permitted everything else
right including the first book because
the blog came out before the book and
what was that blog post that you put
together how to create a million-dollar
business in a weekend featuring
Chihuahua that started this book yeah
that started a lot of me sharing my
Approach yeah and that was wild and it
resonated incredibly well funny sidebar
also if you're curious about some of the
ingredients in the [__] tail that
contributed to Ryan holiday becoming the
face of modern stoicism way back in the
day I think it was called stos ISM 101
on the blog yeah so people can take a
look at Tim do blog for that but let's
start with a completely oblique question
which is a geographic question so we're
sitting here in Austin Texas and before
we started
recording you said something along the
lines of Barcelona is the new Austin m
can you expand on this you know in our
last show which was you were talking
like hey you're in Austin I'm living you
were living in San Francisco you know
tell me about it you're like yeah I
thought about it and now we're here
living in Austin we here and I do think
in my life I've been able to pick things
a little early Facebook a little early
mint a little early social games a
little early group on kind of apps.com
early SAS businesses early and so even
choosing Austin early super early when
did you get to Austin 14 years ago 14
yeah which people were like what are you
doing out there I was like I don't even
know where it is in Texas but it's great
and for me six years ago my buddies Dan
and Ian from tropical MBA they're like
come out to Barcelona for a month and I
got there and I was like that's okay and
it's very hot here in Austin MH so I was
like all right I'll go out there and
after a few weeks I'm really into
cycling I'm into the spandex but really
the cycling out there was just it's
world class it's where Lance Armstrong
got famous like it's what he made famous
actually in a city called Jona so I got
out there and we started training
started drinking at night started eating
the prices are amazing there's a Beach
right there it's basically California
without all the [__] and a lot
cheaper it's a good sales pit yeah
people like want to go to California
like no thank you I do love California
definitely one of my homes and so I just
started going there every single summer
and now this year I spent 143 days and
it's just amazing and then what's even
wild is my girlfriend who I met there
now she's pregnant which is insane she
was saying that the life expectancy of
Spaniards is actually higher than
Americans I believe that I was talking
to her about this and that's kind of
interesting it's like well would don't
you want to live where people live
longer yeah so you have fresher food
everything is walkable so you're like
going downstairs you're like well I'm
going to go get a tomato and there's a
vegetable store and then there's a meat
store and a cheese store you have
Community there we're here where she
comes she lives at my house here we live
out in the west she's like do you see
anyone ever do you ever talk to anyone
she's like where is everyone and so all
these factors combined plus the cost of
living is cheaper it's just been where
now we're spending at least half a year
out there a lot more social fabric too I
would imagine right I haven't
experienced Barcelona much I've spent a
little bit of time there great Tango
scene for people who may be interested
but in Madrid where I spent a bit more
time people are out they're socializing
groups of friends families you just see
more cohesion and at least it seems
maybe technology has changed this and
people are more Ready Player one now in
Spain it's possible it's true most
places but less self-imposed isolation
right than I observe
in the US normally less isolation better
looking people straight up it's got a
higher density of really gorgeous people
I mean Austin's a pretty attractive town
it's okay depends on what you're looking
for it depends yeah recycling it's world
class I like men with man buns and leg
tattoos that's Austin okay okay you're
the right place if you're but like just
everything about it has been such a
blessing to be able to find that and be
able to live my life there and here you
can do both so we're GNA move on to
other things but before we do yeah
Barcelona let's start with a contrast so
Austin for a host of different reasons
has become a Nexus for a few things that
I think we could have expected looking
back from say five years ago we could
have expected Tech right Tech was
already here from a taxation perspective
Etc it made a lot of sense Co
accelerated all of that so you've seen
an explosion of tech I mean within
Striking Distance of where we're sitting
there is an entire skyscraper who knows
how many floors 40 50 floors that is
going to be exclusively Google yeah
which has not yet been opened
commercially speaking right there are a
few retail shops at the bottom that I
think is somewhat predictable the things
I couldn't have predicted or wouldn't
have predicted Austin has become the
mecca of Brazilian Jiu-Jitsu in the
world not just in the United States it
is if not already certainly becoming an
epicenter for comedy standup comedy in
many ways thanks to Joe Rogan and
and his club that he has opened here
what do you think if anything you like
you know what in the next five to 10
years I bet Barcelona could be hot for X
is there anything that comes to mind
because I always looked at Austin as
this highly
Diversified town that was not dominated
by a single industry that's part of what
appealed to me compared to say sfbay
area right
now hasn't quite worked out as I
anticipated but certain
dominant communities and industries are
becoming clear now in Austin any
thoughts on yeah Barcelo I would say
with Austin I'd also add content
creators there's a lot of pretty sizable
YouTube podcasts that have become in
Austin R holiday me you yep definitely a
lot of other people that have moved out
here I would say for Barcelona for me
specifically it's I can see it being the
remote working capital of the world yes
the hours are a little off so maybe
you'd want to go South America but
potentially like just for for having a
metropolitan City especially in Austin
it's hot here 4 months a year so for
mons to be clear what we mean by hot
sorry Centigrade folks I don't know how
to convert this but we're talking like
110 to 120 it's like a lot of the time
38 to 4 Celsius your dog cannot walk
outside my dog's feet will literally
turn into omelets well you were sh me
your floor is literally burnt in your
place from the Sun from the Sun yeah the
previous owner the previous owner left
the solar Shades up and the entire floor
was bleached by the Sun yeah you know
you go to Barcelona I get a co-working
spot go to one co-work but there's so
many out there 500 bucks a month you get
an awesome desk you get really really
fast Wi-Fi everywhere you can use uk.com
uk.com it's like Airbnb but even cheaper
super sick Apartments don't use it yet
because I need to book my
place good luck yeah and then you have
like you know you can go to all these
amazing cities in a weekend so you got
like putraa which is like better than
like Tahoe bigger mountains not as
crowded you've got Costa Braava which is
California coast but even better it's
like European style you have naked
beaches mhm both genders so whatever you
want M we were going to the wrong Beach
depending on how you look at it for a
long time then my buddy's let's go down
the beach all these varietal things that
really make it a nice summer and I like
the balance of having both where there's
the intimacy of being here in Austin
where you can go to Uchi you have people
like you and me and there's a lot of
interesting people here but then also
when it's hot in summer wow now with
entrepreneurship now with remote work
barcelon is a great second home for the
rest of the year tactical question for
people listening and I know this exists
in some countries is there the
equivalent of a digital Nomad Visa or is
it yeah so something that's more
complicated it's way more complicated
than people sound so I literally got the
phone with the immigration lawyer for us
and Europe yesterday I talked to both of
them and this is ties into our entire
conversation and I'll make that
connection in a minute but please
continue so you got off the phone it's
not as easy as it seems there's
basically there's a nomad visa for Spain
right and to be clear it's taken me 18
months and I still don't have it wow and
I have a pretty sizable company I have a
prettyy sizable bank account I went to a
college which you have to do and I've
used a law firm to follow all these
papers and I'm still not there so
sometimes when you're dealing with other
countries even in America there's a lot
of bureaucracy so that's one way to do
it that could take a lot of time second
one is the golden Visa so you spend half
a million in Spain in Spain on a
property and then you can be able to get
a Visa there m the other one that we're
going to be approaching the way I'm
going to do it is called the per Deo
okay so if you can meet someone who is
actually a citizen you don't have to
actually be married you just have to
live with them and be with them you can
get your residency there H so that's
what I'm doing with my girlfriend I see
and so that is one approach get your
green card to be able to get my green
card I'm coming through the Border
legally over there but otherwise it's
it's a three-month tourist visa I think
the NAD Visa it sounds great it's just
literally 18 months and I don't know
1,500 bucks still nothing yeah that's a
lift I mean in terms of energy
commitment and the reason I wanted to
cover this and the reason it ties into
everything is
that I enjoy our
conversations in part because I learn a
lot about the latest and greatest of
whatever you've experimented with
personally and professionally and the
personal part is not a small thing right
because you can create a business that
is a monster of your own making a jail
of your own making it's very easy it's
very easy to do that is the default I
would say and you can also design a
business that allows you to do the type
of thing that you're describing right
and those are
fundamentally different approaches they
seldom happen by accident so why don't
we hop
into the million dooll weekend I can do
one more bonus visa thing that everyone
can consider great bonus this is like a
little secret thing that it's actually
kind of interesting a lot of countries
if you can find your genology use 23 and
me or talk to your grandparents you can
actually get your citizenship through
that so my great-grandfather is from
Poland so that's been one Avenue I've
been considering where if you can
actually find documents which we've been
able to find some I can get Poland
citizenship which is then part of the EU
citizenship yeah so that is another way
of getting in if I didn't have a
girlfriend for people out there go look
up your ancestry and see if that country
will be able to give you a citizenship
yeah and different countries
have different degrees of leniency SL
acceptance depending on how far back you
go my buddy Dan Andrews always says he's
like be mindful of marrying the passport
cuz my girlfriend is Venezuelan but
lives in Portugal that we were in Spain
so it's just a lot of things now to get
her in America has been a nightmare get
her super challenging I'm like
ridiculously challenging the people are
trying to get across the border down
south I'm like if that's easier maybe
we'll just do that I'll put you on my
back and carry you yeah side note if we
look at this is a whole separate
conversation if we look at the
plummeting birth rates right we not
meeting replacement rates for population
growth which is then correlated to GDP
growth and so on in so many
industrialized countries the one
advantage the US has really is
immigration attracting Talent globally
so making it easy or easier is really
Mission critical to the economic and
sort of National Security future of the
United States 100% it's also not as easy
as people realize like I was talking
with the lawyer to get her into America
the other the other Visa lawyer and it's
not you know in 90-day fiance that show
it's like okay you get a fiance boom
boom boom no it's not like that you have
to wait a lot of time you have to spend
a lot of money you can't leave the
country if you do it in America she
can't leave for months or if we do it in
Spain she can't come into America for
years it's incredibly tricky incredibly
complicated yeah so let's zoom out for a
second and we're going to talk about
starting we're going to talk about the
initial stages and process for building
a business or concepting a business in a
very short period of time so we are
going to get to that and we are going to
have a challenge
slash competition offer from Noah later
that you're not going to want to miss so
stick around for that I absolve all
responsibility no
has has verbally committed to all the
indemnities in the world for me so this
this is Noah's thing but I want to talk
about running appsumo because prior to
doing the homework for this conversation
I had no idea that it had grown so much
MH was wild right I agree so 80 million
a year business that's
bananas and what I'm curious about is
being the CEO of such a company
and could you give us an idea
of what the company looks like first of
all just in terms of basic or chart like
how many full-time employees how you
think about structuring the company it's
been interesting and one thing you know
especially for million dooll weekend
which is the Playbook I used and it
started with just me mhm in a basement
in hate Ashbury right for 48 bucks and
that's what's crazy to then okay
everyone can doesn't have to have a lot
of money or time to be able to get to
this point mhm and so that is kind of
wild there are playbooks for starting
low cost starting low risk incrementally
building something that can become the
type of business that you're describing
or larger yeah or not depending on your
priorities right that's why I left SF I
wanted to live I'm not here just to work
all day yeah like and that's why I'm in
Barcelona it's like I want to have a
good balance of enjoying life and making
money the way I want and so app sumo.com
today we have about 75 full-time
teammates I think the word employees is
just kind of archaic mhm and then maybe
25 time contractors and so that's broken
out about six different departments so
we have product engineering department
sales Business Development Department
marketing department operations M so we
go get the best deals on the planet app
Sumo negotiate and seing prices and then
we have to get it on the website so
there's team that helps do do that
customer support team people team and
then a finance and business intelligence
team and are those employees distributed
do they have locations I think they're
real I guess they all have locations
we've gone back and forth over the years
man like I started in a basement I made
every move to Austin and then we got an
office here now we're remote MH and
we're doing stiens for co-working spots
for some of the teammates as an
experiment to see if we can actually
help them either get their home office
setup or co-working setup we've tried
the office it didn't seem like people
actually go we have one now mhm I don't
know if people
go I literally have no clue but we've
definitely downsized from about 50,000 a
month I think our office now is 3500
bucks a month I was going to ask you
about CEO Frameworks that you use on an
ongoing basis so we're going to come
back to that but since you talked about
downsizing and I want to give somebody
who's listening something
tactical right away because we want to
frontload some of those Scooby Snacks to
keep everybody
listening you are a very proactive
negotiator and that can range
from asking for a discount on coffee
which I think we should revisit briefly
yes dude to
the 35 plan I believe that you had for
covid right the I think it was maybe
dropping sales goals assuming a 5%
profit margin something like that yeah
I'd like to know how you negotiate
things down like what are some of the
key approaches so let's say somebody's
looking
at lease of a space for an office that's
not really being used or they're looking
at their credit card statement and
they're trying to tighten the belt
because they want to take some swings at
Entre rship but they want to feel a
margin of safety right how do
you approach this what are some of the
keys to that because this is something I
know you have a lot of practice with
okay I'm not going to do Jewish jokes
but I I love a good deal that's abum
what I is all no it is Jewish to be
clear okay a few things of how I like to
approach negotiating and getting better
prices on things first off this is going
to be counterintuitive but I always say
I'm really bad at
negotiating that's my first line you say
that to the person you're negotiating
against
every time got and and the idea here is
one I am bad because what I'm interested
in is like I don't really want to spend
a lot of time I want to understand what
you want mhm and if I know that what you
want you're happy with what you get and
it's within my circle that's it m i
don't want to spend so much time
actually negotiating so and I think that
lowers people's defenses as well where
I'm just not really good at negotiating
I want to make sure you get what you
want MH and then people like oh great so
that's number one second thing no one
really wants to be guilted I have a
Jewish mother I know about
guilt right that there's a reason Jewish
it's called guilt right like it's not a
coincidence the second thing is no one
will be guilted into being excited to
work with you and the internet is a
small place the world is a small place
me and you how long we been together you
started what the book your book 2007
yeah the book came out in 2007 started
writing in 2005 so we met 2007 2008 2006
2007 maybe earlier before 2006 it comes
around yeah so when people try to dick
you over people kind of grind you you're
like okay I know mhm I'll see you again
yeah right and so for me it's like how
do I have a positive experience where do
you want to do another deal with Noah do
you want to do another discount with
Noah and then lastly I think a lot of
times pricing so one be positive MH have
a good experience because you're
probably going to do this again then I
say lastly what's the actual value
you're negotiating around I think a lot
of times it's like why I want five vers
10 it's like why so have clarity about
why you think it's that price like hey
here's comps here's something that you
can actually base this on mhm so have
something where you're like okay I'm
paying what we do at apps.com is we do a
buy anual review over every single
contractor and every single software
subscription we don't use software we
literally just have a list on
spreadsheets and then so twice a year
you go through the list every single
thing of your sort of recurring costs
yeah so our server costs and electronic
cost a month give or take is 250,000 mhm
contractor teammate cost is somewhere
around one and a half million a month so
you add that up over a year it's a lot
so every biannual Anna who leads our
people team she's amazing goes over that
and then we basically have two columns
which is price of it and then we have
the return on investment or how valuable
we think it is to the company low medium
high and then they literally go through
every single one and see if they can
contact anything that says low MH and
then just get it canceled either get it
canceled or get it negoti down anything
that's high we still ask for a discount
as well MH but we more or less leave
those alone last tip I'll give for
negotiating prices and again I recommend
everyone doing a b annual review
personally or professionally when you
give the numb shut the hell up I don't
know if you've heard this but this is
one of my favorite I do this all the
time I literally did two days ago and
when you say when you give the number
that's effectively what you're asking
for yeah so you know million dollar
weekend and even aba.com in life in
general everything is an Ask MH and so
how I like to do it I bought a sauna MH
and they didn't deliver it for 6 months
and I was a little frustrated so I did a
chargeback people in Europe don't know
about chargebacks you know this
Americans are like I'll charge you back
Europeans are like what is what's
happening here so I charge back and they
contacted me you define a charge back
that's basically you're asking a credit
card company to reverse a charge yes
which everyone should do not all the
time and it happens at abso and we we do
our best to rectify what customer think
is wrong but it's a really nice way of
getting a company's attention yeah
because they get charged for it they get
$35 bill and they get notified like hey
here's a charge back you need to solve
this and so I wouldn't do it all the
time I'm that's not something I'm doing
rightly but if someone like I try to
return something or they didn't deliver
for six months I did a charge back now
I'll talk to the negotiating part so the
owner of the company 3 months later
after he notices it is like hey I got to
charge back man like what the hell and I
was like am I integrity I'm going to pay
for your sauna but let me just tell you
my my experience we have a chat this is
literally 3 days ago and he's like all
right man he's country actually he's
like all right man I got you I'm G hook
you up a little discount there Noah I
was like all right there Craig and he's
like I'm Gonna Give You 10% I was like
okay Craig I was like Craig you know let
me just I think what times when you're
negotiating people do like they go back
and forth emotionally and it's like get
off the emotion and get to the solution
get the result yeah get the result
instead of being right instead of 100%
instead of being righteous with Craig he
said 10% and I said all right you know
well Craig let me just let me just walk
through what happened you guys charge me
13,500 for my sauna which I love it
didn't come for six months you lied to
me every week I think what's the reason
they lied to me it was coming every week
I'd ask every week and they're like oh
yeah it's coming this week for six
months five minutes took it for those
people who've seen snatch what is it a
movie reference people who get it
doesn't matter that's movie reference
people who get it will get it the last
negotiating technique and this is you
know a million dollar weekend we talk
about how to sell better and there a
very simple framework everyone can copy
but with with Craig I said all right
Craig you know let's do 20% and this is
the power move you say your your ask or
your number and you shut up mhm that's
it I don't know if people already do
this or know about this but that is the
power move so the final blow let the
silence to the war just be like 20% and
Craig is like all right now you got a
deal let's get it done and so then we
got 20% I was able to get an extra
thousand bucks off the sauna I'm happy
he's happy we can move forward so that
is a lot of how I like to negotiate and
if you flashback to earlier days right
so smaller company maybe it's when
you're solo yeah maybe it's what you did
before starting appsumo right because
this is not a new habit this is a habit
you've developed over a very long period
of time yeah and I'm looking at
transcript of an interview from mixer G
so I'll throw in I know going into the
archives and wanted to throw this out
there just in case it's helpful to folks
or for just jogging other techniques in
terms of tightening the belt which is
something I did also before starting my
very first company the Sports Nutrition
Company I went through my credit card
statements like okay what can I cancel
what can I get rid of so I feel like I
have more of a buffer right my burn rate
is as low as possible here's what we
have in front of me fact check can't
trust everything you read on the
internet but here's what we have my most
important thing is that when you're
emailing someone I think you've got to
do a few things all right first tell
them the exact price that you want right
so you kind of alluded to that number
two say hey I can't afford this right
now number three say this is what I need
for now we can revisit it in 6 months if
the economy recovers this is a great way
to keep me as a long-term customer it's
a pretty good line right any other
thoughts
on negotiating prices down or out right
just deciding what to cut I think the
bigger concept that I I reflect on for
everyone out there is that you can
actually ask for discounts and I don't
think people realize that yeah I think
that's actually the bigger one of the
bigger things not the only biggest thing
which is I went to you know Ali abdall I
do yeah I don't know him personally but
I've I've had a little bit of contact oh
he's awesome he's like beautiful person
I love this guy and I went to hang out
with him in La two weeks ago I go to his
hotel seems like he's done a very good
job on a whole bunch of different levels
yeah and he's kind about it which I
really admire and I go to his hotel room
I'm like dude sick hotel room really
sick hotel room it's like literally
Corner Santa Monica facing the beach me
and Isaac the videographer were sharing
like a tiny one-bedroom like like
cuddling on a bed like poor people I was
like do not not poor people but like I I
call it small Rich that's the new poor
that's my new term small Rich cuz it
means you know there's still a chance to
get rich soon or yet so anyways I asked
Al I was like how much is his room man
this must be like a thousand a night
he's like you know what mate he's London
he's like you know what mate I just
emailed him and said um I'm doing videos
and stuff in the room do you think you
can give me a little discount on the
room they gave him the room for
free they give him the room for free
just by asking doesn't hurt to ask and
so I think the bigger thing is not
necessarily how to grind other people
and I don't think that's what we're
encouraging at all it's just thinking
like if you can't afford something if
you want something how can you just ask
for it and I think what Tim said I think
what you highlighted from what we were
talking about is I like the phrase whift
what's in it for them just think whiff
like how can I tell them I'll be a
long-term customer that's what you
called out which is great or like hey I
can't afford this but I can't afford
this price so I could do something now
and thinking about how you make it in
their interest like maybe I'll leave you
a review MH and thinking you know more
in that instance makes them more likely
to do it so let's give an example of an
option
practice and I know we've talked about
this and for any number of reasons I'm
just in love with it and that is the
coffee discount because don't practice
your first round on the important stuff
that's ridiculous yeah that's asking for
all sorts of problems and and all sorts
of like self-imposed PTSD if it goes
sideways and then you're not going to do
it again yeah so practice on things that
don't matter right it's kind of like if
you going to have a really important job
interview with your top pick don't make
that your first interview 100% just go
get a bunch of practice rounds with
other companies where you don't care
about the outcome so in this case what
is the coffee discount yeah the coffee
discount it ties all into starting a
business which people are like really
and like yeah does it is the thing it's
you go to anytime you buy coffee tea
anytime you go to a store even a
restaurant you can do it anywhere you go
up to the counter you make your purchase
and you say can I please have 10% off
and then they look at you really strange
and you say well Noah Kagan a million
dollar weekend I'm doing this course I'm
trying out this book they said I should
do it they keep looking at you weird
they go let me talk to my manager okay
fine you get 10% off or they come back
and say no mhm and you get your coffee
and you move on M and then I always love
asking people like what did you learn
about yourself mhm and everyone's always
like I was scared I had courage cuz I
faced my fear and I realize I can do
more things and it's not as scary as it
actually seemed and now you can start
applying that frankly in everything in
your jobs for raises with your dating
asking someone for a date and especially
in business which is hey will you come
on my show hey will you be my customer
hey will you give me feedback hey can I
interview you that's all this whole life
is is asking people things and if you
ask guess what you can get I don't know
when I originally said this or wrote it
but I've it resonated so much that I was
like huh maybe I should think about this
even more myself which was this line
can't believe I'm quoting myself for
God's sake save me this is what the
internet does to you I haven't started
quoting myself with my name signed I
haven't started doing that yet but the
life punishes the vague wish and rewards
the specific ask right okay that was
good and this ties into my earliest
Beginnings prior to the 4-Hour Work week
and I don't know if I've actually talked
about this publicly but when I was
giving the guest lectures in Hightech
entrepreneurship at Princeton twice a
year from 2003 to 13 I think I was
invited by a professor I didn't have any
special credentials other than everyone
else he invited in as a guest speaker
was venture-backed and traveled that
route they had some type of external
financing I was one of his students we
kept in touch we got along really well
Ed sha I've had him on the podcast and
he wanted me to come back to share my
experiences on the front lines because I
was a recent grad also I wasn't decades
out yeah bootstrapping right so I went
back and the Crux of my presentation
every time and it modified you know it
grew and it evolved and the notes for
that ended up becoming the backbone of
the 4our work week as I ran all these
experiments but the the opener was
effectively who here wants to be a
salesperson and no hands would go up
nobody would raise their hand right so
good especially because this is
Princeton right and they're like sales
like makes my skin crawl yeah so you had
people who were maybe going into
entrepreneurship more likely Investment
Banking or management consulting
probably but a lot of them had
aspirations to be an entrepreneur and I
said okay whether or not you want to be
a sales person is irrelevant and if you
don't like that label that's fine but
you have to become a really good
dealmaker you have to become a good
dealmaker love that and a lot of those
presentations focused on the concept
that we're talking about asking for what
you want deciding how to position it
deciding how to really determine what
the other person wants because maybe you
are causing a fuss over something that
is just an indicator of what they
actually want you know what I mean 100%
And there are books that help with this
getting past no is one of my favorites
there many others and that is why we're
spending some time on this are there
other let's just call them Comfort
challenges let's say besides the asking
for a discount on a cup of coffee and I
want to make one modification to what
you said which is maybe the first time
you do this will make it softball fine
so you can ask for the discount and then
you can mention you're doing it as an
exercise for a book or something else
but then when you've tried that once or
twice now you can't say that yeah make
it more uncomfortable yeah are there
other small challenges like that where
people can build their tolerance to
discomfort in a similar way yeah one you
can do right now and so this is
something from the book and it's the
only book I think that you actually make
money in the first few pages and this
something that literally everyone can do
right now ask one friend to invest a
dollar in you right now literally get on
your phone venmo PayPal crypto whatever
it is and just message someone on
Whatsapp whatever it is and say hey I
got this idea for a business or I want
to start a business but I'm looking for
one person to be on my board of advisers
or my investor will you venmo me $1 mhm
and I did this with a guy named Jake
about a month and a half ago and his
hand was trembling he's like
you want to make it harder call the
person don't just text message them call
them and it's silly right and I think
business should be fun I don't think we
should have these day jobs that we hate
all day that seems horrible but this is
a fun thing that you can do just a
little dollar one tiny little dollar and
that's but guess what every billion
dollar company started with dollar MH
and so building up that practice where
you just kind of asked for the dollar
and then you get it like oh [__] that's
the beginning this is going to be such a
a mundane procedural stupid question I'm
going to ask anyway if they're like what
am I getting for my dollar as an
investor what do you say the line I like
to use is I love your support as I'm
starting my business and I'd love for
you to be on my board of advisers so I
can keep you informed as I'm working on
my business MH and it's a way to have
people that that care about you are just
a part of your journey and I think
people are surprised how much people
want them to succeed and so Jake called
his brother Jake called his other friend
Tom they're both like who's Jake Jake is
a guy who read million dollar weekend
and lived at my house for 48
hours I wanted to see if the book work
so he read basically a prototype Galley
something like that yeah and so he
called these two people he said hey Tom
I really love for you to support me can
you send me a dollar right now and he
was shaking Tom sent a dollar live we
saw it on venmo and Jake was
like and everyone can do that right now
especially if you want to start a
business and you want to get going or
guess what if you have a business just
do it to do it to one friend do it to a
colleague do it to your significant
others that's one I I highly recommend
the other one that this is stuff I still
to this day and this isn't they're silly
right and business should be fun and
guess what as you called it out really
well practice on the small stuff so when
you get to bigger stuff it's not as big
a deal like I'm going to people's houses
and knocking on doors mhm that's pretty
scary most of my videos on YouTube are
me going up someone's door I don't know
them and I ask them what do you do for
living that's a very big ask to a
stranger imagine me knocking on your
door here You' be like get the hell out
of here so the other one that I'd
recommend and this is a again these are
Universal you don't need money doesn't
matter your gender doesn't matter how
rich or poor you are you can practice
practice these and build your skills up
and your confidence up to be successful
in business because as you said sales is
the basis of billionaires a lot of
billionaires were really good at sales
if you're not selling customers you're
selling people on your ideas you're
selling people on why they should use
your design specs instead of something
else you're selling them on why
you deserve or at the very least it's
okay that you take a week of paid time
off like you are persuading you are
going to be in the persuasion business
even even if you are the most
antisocial of coders at some point you
have to interact with these bags of
flesh called humans yeah and this is
part of the game it is it is the other
one that's Universal and I do it I did
it last week and it was it was actually
pretty fun is the compliment challenge
mhm it's what it sounds like and so
specifically what I like to compliment
people on is clothing MH I've never been
a good dresser you grew up in California
know
mvin Island so forget about clothing but
yeah you you know you move to the like
you know mvin remember that store mvin
vaguely no man it was bad that's the
only place my mom bought his clothes
from and it it was rough most of my life
and as I got older I was like kind of
want to dress well and so the compliment
challenge is anytime you see anyone with
something nice that you're like that's
kind of a cool hat cool jacket cool
shoes so two weeks ago I was at the Best
Western and as I like to call it it's
the okay Western Hotel it's definitely
not the best she rebranded this lady had
shoes on I was like and then the way I
like to think about it specifically with
these challenges is you have a 3se
second rule for me personally is like
won't negotiate with with Terrace I will
not negotiate with myself MH So within 3
seconds I have to make the decision to
do it just go do it don't even think
about it and then by the time you do it
like that was never so scary and I still
have the fear it's not like at points it
goes away just get a little bit easier
over time so this lady was sitting
having breakfast with her husband and
I'm like I'm bothering her I'm
definitely bothering and that's actually
a really misconception in big in sales
we're like we're bothering the other
people here's it's fascinating I go up
to her like I'm really sorry to bother
you guys but I love your shoes she's
like thank you so much I was like do you
M tell me where you got them from she
like yeah I got him from JC peny I was
like awesome I think my girlfriend might
like those have a great day and she's
like thank you so much that was really
nice of you I was like okay went back to
my chair and so that's that's one of the
misconceptions in sales is that we're
actually harassing or bothering people
when maybe it's actually a good thing
and people need to maybe reconsider
their perception of what a sale is quick
pause if the book title keeps coming up
we're going to have to cut it oh no did
I say it again you're good we can
mention it but if it if there's too much
density we'll have to thin it out a
little bit no worries back to the story
by the way great feedback thank you
that's like a super power I mean that
alone is is great I don't know if you
want to include that in your content but
like I mean [__] if you're okay with it
yeah yeah one of my superpowers at
appsumo one of our values is feedback is
a gift that is also on walls at well the
artist formerly known as Facebook right
feedback as a gift is that what they
said in there yeah oh wow that's the
thing but it is and this is fun okay
yeah if we can keep it in that'd be
great because when I was as an example
right when I was early on preparing ing
for the 4our work week I went to Media
training I'd never done real media
before and they were like you must say
as in my book right in my book mention
the title and I did it I I got really
good at it and um what I would say to
folks if you're on morning television
and you have 45 seconds and they're
going to mispronounce your name and get
your book title wrong yes it's a good
idea to to get it in with longer format
you have the time to to work with nuance
and I will tell people right now look
I'll keep it simple just go buy the
[__] book
because
because i' I've seen what the blog post
has done I've spent enough time with you
I've seen you in action we've
collaborated way back in the day on the
Tim Ferris experiment the TV show got to
see a lot of this stuff live got to
practice a lot of it live so you know
what you're talking about so coming back
to the sales I will
say don't assume that that complimenting
someone or approaching someone is going
to be bothersome or harass them however
there are times when that can be the
case in the sense that I remember in
Silicon Valley man this is part of the
reason why I was like I need to take a
break from this place geographically I
would be at dinners dinners sometimes
with my girlfriend we'd be on a date and
a dude it was always a dude it was
always a dude like some dude in his like
mid-20s would come over and be like hi
Tim and pull up a chair and just sit
down and Pitch me on and start
up and I remember on multiple occasions
there were times when I was not as
delicate about it but I would just be
like John is your name John you didn't
even mention your name John I'll just
call you John I John it does not matter
how good your pitch is right now it
could be the best pitch in the world the
timing is not good yeah and I'll just
share one more that I thought was
amusing which is a Counterpoint although
I will say often times the it's going to
bother someone it's going to be rude
it's going to be fill-in theblank
negative label is an excuse for us to
avoid doing the thing that is
uncomfortable amen however one counter
example we're sitting here in Austin I
was here at South by South by Southwest
so that is a huge Festival here in
Austin great fun and I was on an
escalator and I was exhausted because
I'm an introvert which people may not
realize because I have one-on-one
conversations and then broadcast it to
millions of people but very introverted
I get depleted when I go to events and I
do things like book signings I'm toast
for 2 3 days so I'm on the escalator and
literally like putting my face like
nuzzling into my girlfriend's neck
because I'm trying to hide from the
world and she is she is above me in the
escalator a guy reaches over her
shoulder and Taps me on the shoulder oh
God to [__] be on his startup so don't
do that dude I got a guy in I was in
Barcelona I was in spandex just to be
clear I just finished a bike ride and
this guy pulls up a seat next to me and
he's like you're no a Kagan right I'm
like yeah I'm no Kagan he's like dude
give me a hug I was like I don't know
you he's like you got to come eat my
friends I was like dude I'm just getting
a beer just let me get my Australia damn
and chill out dude and yes I'll come
talk to you and your it was just a
little bit too imposing but you know
just just look I don't want to turn this
into a like total fetch Marathon but I
will say that for me this is very much
an Austin thing too if you meet anyone
for the first time and perhaps I've
spent too much time in Japan who knows
but if I stick out my hand and you say
I'm a hugger oh the worst dude don't do
that and then they beare hug you they be
those are always do like will Ferell
comedy extended hug don't do that guys
don't do that guys do the fist bump do
the bow just about anything is fine
please don't that's so imposing like I'm
a hugger it's like all right I'm a
kicker doesn't mean I'm going to kick
you though yeah I'm a slapper
great so uh Pro tips I'll drop one thing
uh especially in sales we're talking
about challenges by the way all these
challenges do lead up and what I think
has helped me be successful is asking
and practicing and so for sales I have a
little framework it works super well
it's called lot listen options
transition and this is the same thing in
asking just listen to the other person
MH so first off I'm going to listen to
Tim talk to them about their problems if
especially if you're starting a business
you're like let me talk to you about
your shirts what do you like about your
shirts what do you not like about your
shirts tell me more about your shirts
and just listen just think of you're
doing a podcast interview and you're
just interviewing them and getting
feedback okay then you present an option
to your person it's like hey oh you like
shirts what about this shirt at this
price mhm and they say yeah that
actually solves my problem or if you
can't you don't and then you transition
them to all right pay me all right let's
move on to a Next Step let's put in the
calendar which I'm always a huge like
lock it in the cow if you're trying to
get sales always in the cow or how do
you lock it in the cow in a case like
this like what goes into the calendar
I'll give you an example yesterday I was
talking to this woman at a company that
I want to work with and it was like all
right Well we'd like to do something
together cool I'll follow up an email
and I'm like you know let's just do it
right now my phrase is always this I
have my calendar open how does this date
work at this time and that is such an
easier decision for her to then make and
say actually yeah cool let's placeholder
it it also saves so much bandwidth over
time 100% right like you add that up
over as a process right if you're
constantly doing follow-up emails yeah
and I want to make sure I have 10% of
your life is dealing with those followup
emails 100% right let's talk
about what we
left maybe 10 15 minutes ago just
because I like to
bookmark practices at different stages
because I do find that they inform a lot
and I'm also personally curious these
conversations are ultimately always
personal to me so CEO Frameworks yeah
things that you do on a daily weekly or
monthly basis you mentioned the by
anual for lack of better descriptor like
sort of recurring expense review right
you mentioned that already what are some
other things because you've had quite a
bit of practice now yeah let me show you
a few cuz I think it's kind of cooler
when you get to see it so every single
day at appa.com can I say the website or
is it am I saying it too much that's
fine every when I every
single.com bleep.com yeah we'll bleep it
out you can check this out I think you
can and you could talk through it I'm
happy you can share these numbers so
every single day this is something Keith
R boy does and okay so this is in so
every day we have a daily pulse that's
what we call it and let's zoom out for
one sec M have One Singular goal that's
what I've learned from Zuckerberg and
that's what I do at appa.com mhm and so
with abs.com this year our One Singular
goal is $45 million net revenue MH
that's net gross sales is definitely
around 77 to 80 million depending on how
the year ends and then every single day
there is this slack bot that posts like
all of our key metrics that lead to our
number one goal and it's tied into
automation yeah so what are you using
there we're using zapier and then we use
snowflake when we have a twers business
intelligence team but anyone can do this
on a spreadsheet just every day you have
one goal how you doing could I say this
for a sec yeah yeah go you can talk out
some of the numbers it's pretty
interesting so we have data updated
through right this is a pul spot so it's
being automatically posted you're not
manually pulling this but you could yeah
and you can also by the way if you're
just starting out just have a
spreadsheet and check it every single
day yeah so you have month to date
actual as compared to goal so that's
that is in and of itself meaningful
right so you got total gross sales 4.3
million let's call it versus
4.43 8 million total net revenue grow
profit aov which is average order value
yep and new buyers total buyers Plus
members those are subscribers those are
our VIP customers VIP customers daily
sales which is broken out new buyers new
buyer conversion rate new versus
existing buyer gross sales month to
date that's an interesting one and then
Daily kpi Report with monthly
projections so the kpi key performance
indicator so this is quite a bit of
stuff right yeah and I'm wondering if
you had to 820 this for your business
right now yeah because I'm not sure how
Keith R boy does this or describes it
there are I believe examples at say why
combinator of talking about the single
weekly metric right picking one or two
weekly metrics that are tracked over
time and you're trying to get that to
compound at 10% a week or whatever the
number might be what would you for
choose as your your kind of 8020
priorities in that list right now for
everyone out there it could be different
right we're more of an e-commerce site
with with our business there's three
numbers that I would just look at right
three numbers add up so again start with
one goal what is your goal and what's
your date for that goal so our goal is
from zero January one to the end of the
year how do we get 45 million net
revenue the three kpis that lead to that
it's B just three for us traffic so how
many people are coming to the site how
many people actually buy which is our
conversion rate and then how much do
they spend which is our average order
value that's it that's all I would look
at at and now that's the the most
simplest version of it so if you have
traffic times how much people buy how
much they spend that gives you your
Revenue numbers mhm but then we have
subn numbers that's where it gets
complicated but if I had to do 8020 it
would be that MH now what other people
need to be thinking about though is what
are the things that impact those three
KPS that's how you now get way more
complicated just for fun if you had to
pick one of those three to optimize for
2024 which would it be with app sumo.com
top of the funnel so traffic conversion
or average order volume if I only could
pick one thing out of all of it
yep I would actually pick just number of
deals for our business number of deals
yeah so every business has the number of
products that you're offering which
should help with I imagine the
conversion and traffic yep yeah and so
for every business out there what's the
core input that leads to your main
outputs MH let's just take a lot of
different examples so YouTube lately and
this has been a big transformation for
me is I'm sing unambitious goals okay
tell me more you know I think it's silic
value if you're not 10 Xing and I L I
was with our board a month ago like if
you're not 10x no you're failing and I
was like okay I've read that book
and and so I got that t-shirt too guys I
get it know 10x everything is written by
people that haven't 10x the business
there's cores for everything so the core
for my YouTube channel is two videos a
month mhm that's it that's what I found
gets me to the main metrics that I need
and there's supporting metrics around it
but that's my core there abs.com as of
now it's give or take around I'd have to
ask Sean he runs the high level but it's
about 35 deals a month if we can do
amazing software deals a month we hit
our targets more or less and so for your
business what's the core numbers we
talked about this in the past but what's
the core number you can really just like
everything kind of works backwards off
of and so for us it would be deals so
we're going to talk about other
Frameworks and then we're going to at
some point we are going to come back to
YouTube because I have questions around
that sure top three bottom
three what is that you know you gave me
feedback early in the show which is
great that's awesome that's how you
improve I don't know if people don't
realize that like the only way you look
at yourself is with a mirror yeah and
that's the same thing in your
relationships to ask your partner today
right now hey what am I doing well or
what do you want me to improve on and
we're going to come back to this but how
much money have you spent on coaches
would you say in the last 5 to 10 years
myself and the team uh easily over a
million okay easily over a million so we
we'll get into that we yeah I like
feedback that's how I can get better it
doesn't mean I accept all the feedback
but it means I can acknowledge all the
feedback and make a decision so T3 B3 is
something like it's from Travis actually
at Uber and so the idea and Andrew Chen
who's one of my best friends and adviser
brought it to me he's been on the show
basically just like every quarter it's
so light I just don't like sometimes
feedback cuz it's like these 18 Pages
I'm like I don't know what to do yeah
you have 18 things [__] to do it's so
much just tell me the top three things
I'm doing great here don't worry we can
cuss what are the top three things you
love that I'm doing so I know I can
continue it and what are the bottom
three things that I can improve on three
things is definitely doable if not three
just even do one mm you can do T1 B1 and
I just have it in my calendar I think
more things you can just have automatic
in your calendar the better so I just
have my calendar ask team T3 B3 every
quarter and so right now in your
business if you're in the junior
Department if you're the leader of the
company or even in relationships
whatever it is just go ask your partner
ask someone that you trust and respect
hey what is the top three things I'm
doing what are the bottom three and and
do that regularly and you will be able
to keep improving can you give any
examples of of real T3 B3 so on my desk
I print mine out M because I want to see
it I want to know what I'm what you're
doing well you're probably going to
continue but what you can improve is
cool so the team gave me feedback that
I'm they want more autonomy that I'm too
much up in their
ass that I'm like yeah like and this is
the funniest part everyone's like I'm
not a micromanager I'm like dude
everyone who says that is okay it's kind
of like if if you see on a dating app
anyone who says no drama you're like oh
you love
drama huge red flag huge red flag so
they wanted more autonomy so that was
interesting to try to and then ask for
an example like what's an example or
what's a moment give me a solution that
we make sure that as it comes to it so
for instance with abo.com
I love going through our credit card
bill you know our credit card bills
sometimes like November because Black
Friday it's about a million dollars
almost a million dollars and normally it
can vary between three and five that's
on customer acquisition like paid
acquisition Facebook s or Amazon bill
50k a
month a lot of different ads just so I
understand Amazon bill you're talking
about AWS AWS yeah yeah so I was going
through every transaction and would be
like a $9 transaction I would love if
your Amazon bill is just [__] your
employees are buying as gifts AWS I mean
well as you get bigger you also have
checks and balances someone actually
tried to scam us for 30k a few weeks ago
which was super impressive but I was
going through these credit card bills
and if we talk about coaches we have a
CFO coach for the VP Finance she's a CFO
of MailChimp M pretty good job you know
pretty cool company we're in a meeting
and she's like Noah you know we talk
about autonomy we talk about trust do
you think going through the credit card
transactions and messaging people about
a $10 purchase is really autonomy and
not trusting your vpa Finance Kevin who
can do this and I was like
good point I stopped looking at credit
card bills mhm so that was one of them
the other B3 from this quarter was
around longer term Vision I'm much more
of a tactician and I like getting action
I like getting movement and the team was
like you need to chill out and think
longer for us and come back with some
type of longer plan and so the last six
months of the year I was really thinking
about what do we want to do in the next
three years because I've been so focused
in in business and generally about
one-ear segments mhm so we spent so much
time and now we have like a 2026 Vision
I think this is also very common it's
not true for everyone but very common
for people who've done a lot of
bootstrapping yeah more so than people
who have raised a bunch of money yeah
where a board understandably wants to
know what the hell your long-term yeah
what your long-term plans are because
they want to realize their Equity their
return yeah that was the feedback I got
from the team they're like get out of
the day-to-day let us do it we got it
and just start moving the process
forward so it was thinking about like
talking to customers talking to Partners
thinking about ourselves like what do we
like doing what are we great at and
where can we be in three years and then
bringing that back to the team
incorporating them getting them buying
that was something I got feedback in the
past like hey you're just making
decisions without us mhm so yeah by the
end of the year I think mid November now
we have a three-year vision and base
camps towards that Vision base camps
project management you mean not
necessarily basecamp.com but base camp
specifically what are Milestones so our
destination is to be able to distribute
software tools for entrepreneurs that's
what we love doing I love promoting
things M and so how do we be the number
one place to distribute software tools
not just deals with software tools and
then what are the different key
Milestones numerically as well as from
what we want to do in the business
Within These separate years to be able
to get there in 2026 so that was
feedback directly from the team mhm that
they told me and then we do this for
everyone in the company the top three
bottom three yeah how do people track
that or how do people keep it present
right because it is one thing having
just come off of an offsite myself and I
actually think we did a good job with
this because we sort of assigned
ownership next steps and then did
working sessions during the offsite like
okay let's actually get these things in
motion because it's great to have a
bunch of meals have some wine walk
around talk about Big Ideas oh we're so
excited let's take a team photo next to
the paper on the wall and
then like right back to status quo how
do people keep these top three bottom
three present or maybe a better way to
word it is how do they keep themselves
accountable a few things that work for
us so one is
scorecards everyone gets a scorecard if
you're an abum get a scorecard and so I
can show you an example of it I focus on
the leadership scorecard so I have a
company scorecard what are our top three
things we're trying to do in q1 mhm and
Sean he's our head of Revenue alanus
she's our coo they each have a scorecard
which just what are your top three
things based on what we're trying to do
in q1 okay this would be for q1 yeah and
so that is a helpful way where maybe
it's something they want to improve or
maybe it's just something that they need
to work on or it's just an outcome that
we want and then we agree on what those
are mhm they propose it I review it and
then we decide it got it it doesn't mean
necessarily like hey it's going to be
one of their B3 but that for me is like
the three things that they want to get
better at or they want to accomplish the
other thing I would say you know it
sounded like you guys had a planning
session and all this stuff told you we
have a three-year vision and then we
have like all this stuff but on Monday I
was with one of my coaches Dan putt from
reboot and I was talking to Dan I was
like I don't know if we're on the same
page what we're doing because I'm not
really clear he's like well if you're
not clear they're definitely not
clear and uh I was like oh that's
interesting right it comes from the top
how are you leading by example yeah if
I'm not clear where we're going to go
necessarily in the next quarter like
does everyone else know so we had a a
meeting that that night I was like
everyone needs to bring the their top
scorecard projects we need a line on
them make sure they're tied to the main
thing have a one pager around it m had I
mean the next day everyone brought their
stuff and we have a one pager that ties
all this together and so now being very
very clear like what's our number goals
what's our key projects and by the way
this is something that's
counterintuitive in businesses is like
if there's not fighting you're not
really getting the best ideas like I
want more people saying no like the best
people at Facebook when I was there were
always saying no to Mark and I was
always like yeah Mark that was a pretty
good idea that's may I got fired but
over time I've realized that challenging
respectfully is very healthy and so you
ask about scorecard you ask about
feedback and all that it's ask for
feedback reality be clear and what
success is that's what a scorecard is
it's like here is success for me with
our work mhm and then you can be able to
measure against that in a very clear
amount of time we're going to come back
to saying no pretty quickly but because
a big part of enabling yourself to say
yes to the things that matter is being
able and equipped to say no yeah so I do
want to come back to that other
Frameworks that you would like to
mention the other one I do that changed
everything for me in the past two years
especially as a CEO was a weekly review
and so I only have three questions and
really noticing what you actually do a
lot of people like I have all these
Frameworks and then you ask them like a
year later like yeah I don't use it
again so maybe they've evolved it but
really it's not sticking and so this is
one that sticks with with me and I can
show you it's it comes up on my phone so
every week I get a slack bot here it is
you can see so it says complete your
Friday weekly review so today is Friday
as we're we're chatting you can click on
it MH and there's three questions and
the three questions are very very simple
it's how was the week one through five
and why mhm and this is you could do
whether you're CEO or whether you're a
junior person oh this goes to a Google
form yeah and so we track it we track
the ratings every week one is sucked
five is fantastic yeah so this week was
a five this week crash that's thinking
about okay what made this week a five
what happened this week I got to hang
out with you we had lack of clarity on
Monday on Tuesday we dialed in our q1
planning and everyone was like super
hyped on that I finished executive
compensation which was challenging about
how much people get paid so this week
was a five and then explaining line
adding all those different things and
it's not always like I just bullet point
I don't necess need to write stories
number two thing especially is my
leadership style I noticed I was very
inconsistent yeah were you consistent so
my number two question is was I
consistent this week 1 through five
basically because I'd go into a meeting
and I would just start [__] ripping
on people like I was meeting with
Mitchell and man and I'm just like
[__] all over them I'm like your
ideas are sucky and I wasn't coming with
Solutions M that week was a
three that was not a good idea because
as a leader you want consistent
experience for your the people you work
with and you're being consistent based
on feedback you've received from the
team and your top three bottom three is
that sort of a a little bit it's also
this is more my own subjective opinion
got it this is how you feel yeah mhm I
found this really really helpful and
then last question is what are my top
three for next week so it makes me be
very more focused about okay I have a
singular goal we have q1 priorities now
I can break these down to smaller levels
and say like okay this upcoming week
what are the three things you want to
work on then with my executive assistant
and our chief of staff we can help
realign my schedule like is that
actually what I'm working on next week
or is it a bunch of other things m one
tool we stop using because it cost money
so we sto paying for it but there is a
tool that does this T3 B3 and then
follows up and you can have all of it
but I was like I think we can do it in
Google forms for cheaper is lattice
lattice Lattis hq.com it's Sam Altman's
brother Jack got it but it was like
15,000 a year and I was like I think
Google forms for free a year can do
pretty equivalent and just it's a little
more work on the team shout out
Charlotte and Anna and Angelina for
helping facilitate it but yeah that
actually will do your tracking and then
you could double check how you are
against it versus Google spreadsheets is
comparable Q on top and singular goal do
you want to talk about either of these
yeah so a lot of it when you're trying
to go anywhere in your business is like
where do you going to be by the end of
the year so right now for anyone who's
watching this it's coming out in January
where are you going to be December 31st
2024 and just pick a destination with
the time most people don't do either
they're like and you dude you've
influenced so many people on health like
I just want to be healthier what does
that mean to be healthier yeah so be
more clear on your goal and your
destination that's something that
Zuckerberg I've talked to you about it
where he brought me in a room he's like
I want to get a billion people
MH oh like wow that's pretty cool and
this is when we had 10 million yeah
that's a big one that was amazing it was
exciting and so have a very clear
singular goal that you want to
accomplish but maybe it's like a
thousand subscribers mhm and my goals
lately are much more unambitious because
I want to focus on goals I can sustain
could you give an
example of what that looks like so with
appa.com in the past if we didn't 2x a
year I'm like oh it failed and you'll
hear this you'll say like shoot for the
stars and if you at the Moon you're good
but also that means I'm running really
fast mhm you burn out because you're
working really hard and you're not
getting where you want to go yeah and so
now with abso General growth range is 5
to 10% a year mhm and so this year for
2024 I believe it'll be around
7% and the reason that is is because if
I can do 7% over year after year after
year after year yeah you end up the worm
Buffet of ab suumo exactly and the other
thing that I've noticed through these
unambitious goals and I'll give more
examples is that it creates more freedom
for taking 10x experiments MH so we're
doing a lot more content this year by
the time this comes out we're going to
be trying doing like an alternative to
product hunt and some of these other
options but if we're so f focused on
having to grow revenue and do all these
things you don't really have oxygen to
experiment in a way that feels confident
so same thing with my YouTube channel
I'm going from 1 million to 1.25 million
this year you know like 25% but you know
we've been going 50% and that's because
I would say we've had less aggressive
goals MH and so thinking about that for
everyone out there I do think Silicon
Valley and what they're telling you oh
you got a 10x that's because these
investors don't care if people fail I
would add to that yeah this is super
important I'm glad you're bringing it up
because I do like
how some of these outrageous questions
break your mental models or your
assumptions about what you can or can't
do right so how could you achieve your
10 year goals in the next six months
love that great that's an excellent
thought exercise but if you are applying
to yourself as a bootstrapped
entrepreneur 10x are bust and if let's
just say well-being or happiness is
reality minus expectations yes you can
paint yourself into to a precarious
corner and you can paint your team and
employees into a very precarious
Corner in the venture-backed power law
distribution of startups and Venture
Capital there are a few things you got
to realize the first is
that investors are banking on that kind
of power Law return with in Tech so
they're looking at huge possible
multiples right so they could make a,x
on something that breaks out this
happens and that pays for all the losses
other invisible I would say invisible to
the public factors
include the incentives you may not see
in the headlines for instance if a
Founder is able to take money off the
table with large rounds of
financing they're already in the black
right and then
for the company outcome to have a huge
impact on their quality of life they're
willing and able to make enormous
outsized
yeah Bets with ridiculous Ambitions
because guess what it's not in the news
but they already have 20 million in the
bank they're good and this is why I
think what you're saying is really
important like the consistency matters
and I want to tie this because
everything is related to everything in
some respects and I want to talk about
YouTube briefly we are going to talk a
lot about building but guys these are
the
ingredients that allow you to build an
experiment consistently you need to
develop certain attributes and
Frameworks we can talk about kpis and
goals and what we want to achieve
there's a survivorship bias and
Entrepreneurship where you tend to hear
about the success stories 100% right one
of the things you have done on YouTube
I'm not sure if this is going to be
fertile ground for
for for for harvesting so we'll see but
you've asked a lot of millionaires
billionaires versions of was it worth it
what do you regret Etc are there any
takeaways from that that were either
nonobvious or that have really stuck for
you right because it's easy
to find every year some version of the
article that is like so and so talk to
people on their deathbed and they all
said I wish I'd spent more time with my
family and less time in the office like
okay fine right don't neglect your
health fine I get it like these these
are all kind of predictable things you
would expect and no one on their death
bed if they don't want to be considered
like a miserly [__] is going to say my
family sucks I really wish I'd spent
more time in the office they're just not
going to say that as their legacy that's
what I'm
going so has anything really stuck with
you from those conversations or lines of
questioning was it worth it if there
were any regrets things they would have
done differently for context for the
listeners interviewed John Paul deoria
founder of Patron tequila Paul Mitchell
Hair
Care Paul or fail founder of Kinko sold
that for 2.4 billion John Paul sold
Patron for 3.5 billion founder of
Qualcomm hundred billion dollar
company there's a few things that have
stood out from chatting with
them one none of them became
billionaires within 20 years not one
like not paper money words it's coming
up and down super quickly or crypto
billionaires where it can go away took a
long time mhm long long time number two
they all got rich and this is kind of
people know these things just like you
said like death bed people know to spend
more time with their family but they
don't do it mhm this is another one they
all got rich in one way just one thing
John Paul dya just pal mital hair care
then he able to do it again which is we
can talk about that there's something
there Kinkos just copers Larry janeski
just basements right Michael hudner just
ships but all of us are like no I'm
going to
diversify yeah but then you think about
all these people it's like ah they just
did one thing two other things I would
comment from billionaires two to three
they're all entrepreneurs mhm they
weren't W2 employees yeah they hire W2
people the richest people on Earth they
hire W2 people and so it's realizing
like oh maybe this entrepreneurship
there's some upside to that mhm the one
that you commented on another highlight
there and this is from John Paul deoria
which I thought was super powerful and
this is something you start noticing
with billionaires they're actually all
really good at
sales and that is a skill you're like oh
it's asking how can I practice it and
John Paul deoria I don't have hair you
don't have hair he was like give me your
hand I'm going to put on lotion and he
like rubbed it on my hair he's like
how's that feel I was like it feels
actually pretty good he's like how your
hands feel I'm like they feel good I
literally went home and bought Paul
Mitchell hair
care I went home and bought it and he
was just like what I like to do is find
the best product that exists and make
sure it's a product people reorder I was
like oh that's smart and then I I'm
really good at selling and I was like Ah
that's really interesting so so there's
something about selling I would say that
stood out for me and then lastly yeah I
think I would say
50/50 seemed like they could be happier
I just don't know if they all seemed as
happy as I would have imagined I'm like
dude you're a billion you can literally
do anything you want all day forever and
I think like John Paia for me stood out
where he was just very kind y he was
kind with me he was kind with the staff
he was kind where like he sold Patron
and he sent a $50 million check that day
mhm and he felt like he had a good
balance I would say the Austin balance
of like I'm not trying to be a Silicon
Valley work but I'm trying to work make
a lot of money and have a great life and
I admired that yeah he gives me that
impression I've had him on the podcast
and what that proves to me is that it's
possible yes they're a lot of they're a
lot of prick billionaires yes a lot but
you don't have to be a prick it's not a
prerequisite you don't have to be Gordon
gecko yeah you don't have to but I would
add to that is that there are many
different ways to be good at sales right
when I first graduated from school and
and when I first moved to Silicon Valley
and I was selling fiber channel storage
area networks and I was the lowest paid
sales guy which I learned because a
spreadsheet got emailed to the wrong
place and one of my buddies was like bro
you're going to love this and he showed
me the he showed me the annual salaries
and I was like you know theow barely
above the receptionist which I was
actually okay with because it was
commission based but didn't love the
fact that I hadn't negotiated on the
front end but at the time I was pretty
desperate cuz I I had gone without a job
for a while my parents were like so you
can stay here as long as you want but
what's going on the point I want to make
is I had a desk in a chair in an
emergency exit it was like shoehorned
into a fire exit totally not up to code
but I took a lot of opposite approaches
from other sales guys who' come in from
bigger companies like EMC and there were
some great sales people from EMC as as
an example they had a really good
training culture really good hiring
practice generally competitive athletes
or former competitive athletes but the
approach I took was two things I'll just
mention this briefly because it might
alleviate some of the allergic reaction
that people have to this word sales yeah
the first is that I looked at the
biggest block right that's in the vein
of the task that hinders your task is
your task and what I realized I couldn't
get the deal makers on the phone I
couldn't get the CEOs and CTO who would
have to Greenlight a seven figure
investment on the phone because there
were so many Gatekeepers so I just did
the opposite of what I saw around me
which was instead of making calls during
9-5 I just made calls before and after 9
to5 and guess what those people who are
working dogs you know men and women who
have really gotten to the top still tend
to work a lot by and large and so they
would pick up the phone the second was I
studied the tech inside and out to the
extent that when we got to the point of
closing a sale and sometimes they'd get
handed off to accounting and the
accounting department or the vpa finance
would ask them who's your sales guy and
they would say I don't know who my sales
guy is and then eventually they'd be
like oh wait is Tim my sales guy because
I came in
with not quite the knowledge of an
engineer but I spent all my time with
the engineers right so I had technical
conversations I'd be like oh well let me
guess like you probably have this Solara
system and this and this and this and
using this and this you might have
problems with this d da da d da
and you can approach it in a technical
way as one example with certain products
it doesn't have to be Glen Gary Glenn
Ross right yeah so I just wanted to to
mention that the following I'm curious
for you this is something I've been
thinking a lot about is how come
immigrants are so successful MH and
specifically I think one they have they
you can control their attitude and I
think they have good attitudes about
like I got to figure this out and the
second thing is effort there's no limit
on effort there's only a limit on time I
was really curious because especially
with for work week I just remember your
effort was insane and so I wanted to
know and this is sales right sales is
like all right well I'm going to put in
effort to see if I can help this person
if I believe I can so I wanted to hear
more I was curious to hear more about
like what effort you put in because I I
just remember the time I was like who is
this guy man he's working hard into the
book itself like the the writing or the
launch the launch the launch if I think
back to the launch of that first book I
still approach my
launches very similarly believe it or
not as the tools have changed and the
technology and the platforms have
changed the general principles that I
used I still use to this day for
instance for every launch book or
otherwise I have looked at the landscape
and interviewed people so for the book
for instance I interviewed and you can
interview people who might seem Out Of
Reach keeping in mind I had no platform
no nothing at the time I remember but I
just had to reach out and ask and if you
get somebody on a good day and you you
know maybe you take your hat off put it
in your hand and yeah do a little
begging best writing authors were very
forthcoming with their time so in a
number of instances I was able to
interview best writing authors what I
mean by that is real pros Masters and
prolific non-fiction writers who had
very very high quality output on their
writing process so I did that prior to
writing the book then
seeing that the end was near and this
was all on a schedule although I faced a
lot of hiccups and a lot of challenges
along the way so it wasn't a straight
line but when I knew that my book was
probably going to be delivered was
scheduled to be delivered in let's just
say 3 months I started interviewing best
selling authors which are not always the
same as best writing authors and the
questions revolved around their most
recent launches and specifically the
vehicles or formats or people who seem
to be diminishing an impact and those
that seem to be ascending an impact and
those that were ascending an impact I
assumed rightly at the time and this has
been true almost every time would be
uncrowded so for instance for the 4our
work week it became clear even then that
television and radio seem to be
television especially television seemed
to be diminishing in its impact on sales
okay nonetheless the dominant playbook
in included tons and tons and tons of
say morning TV but almost every
bestselling author I spoke to said by
and large not worth the effort they said
however there are a few other things
that have been impressive and notable
number one is that certain radio
programs like MPR and so on move a lot
of books this is again 200 let's just
call it 6 prior to the publication in
2007 and then towards the end of 2006
and I actually remember this because
we're recording this at the end of
December and I remember sitting at my
parents kitchen table after Christmas
and sitting down to really put together
a plan for the first book and another
pattern that had emerged is people said
you know I'm not really a tech person
but there are these things called
blogs and for whatever reason these
single author blogs move a lot of books
and not a single person I recall and
publish and gave a [__] about blogs so
what I decided to do I also had a very
self-imposed and also practically
limited budget for the launch so for me
it was like 5 to 10 grand I can't
remember had a huge
whiteboard and decided to make my
target blogs and there were many
conversations that went into this but
decided to put my effort into blogs
what's the most crowded Channel I'm not
asking it just about the formats but
also the means of reaching bloggers
what's going to be most crowded blog
comments email these are the most
crowded so I took my budget and
allocated it to in-person travel to
events where in the hallways and at
After parties and so on I could have
drinks around or with bloggers and I
spent all my time in the lounges spent
all my time in the waiting
areas and
that is where I committed my investment
of time and money who knows if that was
the right thing to do the only thing to
do maybe I just got lucky but it worked
incredibly well and I'll just give one
more recommendation and actually people
can find a talk I gave ages ago at South
by Southwest which was called how to
build your network and record time or
some clickbaity sounding headline but it
does deliver it explains a lot of this
and also how IED used South by Southwest
similarly for the book because South by
was where the book really broke out yeah
but there was a bunch leading up to it
so this is going a little long but it
might be helpful for folks rule number
one be nice to everyone and this isn't
some feel-good snow white you know
hummingbirds landing on your hands kind
of things this is the right thing to do
but it's also the most practical thing
to do and I'll give a real example I
went to blog World Expo or something and
I'm hanging around didn't go to any
sessions in this particular case a lot
of folks had pointed out Robert scoble
as a power broker hugely influential
which which he certainly was and uh
super sweet guy as well and at that time
I'd had no contact with him he was the
hottest girl at the prom right everybody
wanted to talk to him I didn't really
know how to navigate the event but I
knew there would be people who were
familiar with it so I went to a lounge
and I think it was a Seagate lounge or
something like that way back in the day
and there was a woman checking people in
and kind of handling the inbound traffic
and I just struck up a conversation I
was like I bet you're meeting everybody
I don't know what I'm doing I'm working
on my first book I'm kind of lost here
and we just talked like all that was
true right we talked and we talked and
we talked and I was explaining and I'm
here I laid out my whole plan right I
was like well really my best option is
to focus on the blogs because the
publisher owns a bunch of different
territory this is not their first rodeo
but it's my first rodeo so this is kind
of key there were a bunch of things that
I assumed were off limits for me right I
don't understand radio the Publisher's
going to handle radio I don't understand
television publisher or other publicists
are going to handle that so the one area
I felt where I could play and
potentially leverage things was blocks
so I'm explaining all of this well guess
what that woman who was checking people
in turned out to be Robert sco's wife
and she was like oh you should meet
Robert and then that led to meeting
Robert I'm pretty sure I gave him sent
him a galley and and I made it
absolutely zero expectations so first of
all I was like if it would be of
interest I can send you a galy after I
described the book for certain facets of
it I said what I can do also because
you're not going to probably have time
to read the whole book I'll just put in
a couple of posits for like the four or
five pages that I think you'll find most
interesting most tactical and he's like
great sent it off that turned into a
blog post he put up about what I'm
reading something like that went nuts I
don't recall the exact timing that was
before or after South by Southwest and
South by Southwest was in March talk
about sales right I pitched myself to
Hugh Forest at the time who I believe
was director of programming just for
South by Southwest interactive not music
not film at the time it was like the
redheaded stepchild nobody gave a [__]
about interactive or Tech it was just
nerdville was small that was also the
year that Twitter launched publicly at
South by you could see all the Tweets in
the world on one big screen TV where
they were scrolling through in real time
and Hugh to this day I feel a Deb of
gratitude so part of the reason I come
back to South by every year is because
I'm I feel like it's just karmically the
right thing to do and Hugh is now
running pretty much the whole show I
believe at this point but I got a last
minute cancellation in like the
cafeteria like the Adobe sponsored
cafeteria somebody backed out I took a
last minute SP
I gave a presentation on the 4our work
week I was able to print up Flyers
beforehand which I did very last minute
and I am blanking on his name I feel
really badly about this but it was the
developer behind
Firefox like Ross yes and he had very
graciously given me a quote for the
4-Hour Work week he read a galley and I
can't remember how that came together I
owe him a de of gratitude as well but I
printed up Flyers with that quote Yeah
with a couple of other quotes based on
gyss and encourage people to attend this
cafeteria you put up flyers for the
event I handed them out like I had
people handing them out I put them up
all over Austin right printed them out
I'm sure at
Kinkos and I practiced to my friend's
garage cuz I was crashing on a friend's
couch and I remember practicing in his
garage with his Chihuahua you mentioned
Chihuahua he had three Chihuahuas and
clearly the chihuahuas do not understand
the content of my talk but I used them
as the gauge of whether I was engaging
or not so if they started like wandering
around then I had to change my mode I
had to be more Tony Robins and I prepped
I prepped I prepped I prepared my ass
off for this thing like it was my first
and last opportunity to nail it and got
up on stage I had this entire
presentation with all the visuals of
course what happens laptop dies and so I
had to improv and just do voice only
which I think ended up being a very good
thing
and made autoresponders available I gave
people this was key and this is
something you do very well I gave people
real time challenges I was like here's
something you can try today you're going
to be going to a lot of sessions at
South by you're going to take a lot of
notes here's what I suggest everybody
gets busy things get lost here are a few
things you can try today here are a few
things you can try in the next week
related to autoresponders send me
feedback let me know how it went go on
my blog let me know I will give you also
feedback like constructive
advice and it just went ballistic it
went ballistic and that set the
conditions such that I could execute on
other things but lest people think this
was this home run International
phenomenon from the GetGo that's not
what happened it did hit the extended
bestseller list in its first week but
keep in mind the publisher only printed
10,000 copies nobody expected it to do
anything and with those copies sold the
vast majority of them but that was not
enough to hit the real print bestseller
list for advice how too especially which
was hyper competitive at the time it hit
the extended list so people in the
business knew that it was on the list
but not in the print edition it took an
additional five or six months if I'm
doing the math correctly to get to
number one on the New York Times for the
monthly business list and then it just
stayed there for years but to answer
your question in terms of
effort effort isn't enough effort is not
enough you need a means of focusing that
effort so for me I used this what's
uncrowded what's overvalued what's
undervalued that's how I found podcasts
for the 4our chef that's how I found
other things for the earlier
books and that's how the 4-Hour chefs
sold whatever 100,000 plus copies in its
first week was because I jumped on these
new things called podcasts that is also
the impetus behind me then starting my
own podcast in
2014 but you're right I put a lot into
it because first and foremost and now
I'm getting on my Soap Box again but I
really really really really put
everything into that book like I did not
leave anything behind I put it all on
the playing field and based on early
feedback and based on also
the
many feedback forms many questions I had
asked many revisions I had made for
years workshopping it in classes I knew
this stuff worked like I knew it worked
I knew in other words right talking
about appsumo and your metrics like I
knew it converted I just needed top of
the
funnel and that led me to the to the
blog so wow very similar approach that I
would take today with most things you
seemed a lot happier when you recounting
that story like I was noticing like
earlier in the show you're kind of like
I don't know if you felt frustrated or I
don't know how I don't know how you were
feeling you seemed excited and like
proud honestly I think that maybe we can
talk about this I mean we're also
recording audio so we can we can throw
it in but it's like it's so tempting and
often the case right when you're in the
weeds and you're just running through
this jungle with a machete trying to
make [__] happen and it's hard and
things are going wrong and you think
about that as the thing you have to do
to get to the other thing but then you
get to the other thing meaning like you
reach some escape velocity with your
business success and then you're like
okay this is the thing I thought that I
was getting through other things for and
I'm happy with where I am but I'm making
trains run on time and that's cool I'm a
Swiss operator on some type of transport
platform and I'm tweaking things I'm
pulling levers I have other people doing
a lot of the grunt work but those early
chapters when I look back like that's
where so much of the juice is like so
much of the excitement yeah for me yeah
where you're like [__] my computer broke
right got to fix it got to figure it out
got out fers [__] you know all right
Flyers like flyers okay like I'm going
to give out flyers like flyers okay like
I don't have anybody who's around cuz my
friend has to work like all right I'll
give the talk to the dogs like all right
like yeah and you get a chance this is
true later too but like you really get a
chance to prove how resourceful and
creative you can be because you don't
have a huge bank account to play with
you don't have tons of employees to
delegate to things that often times they
shouldn't do in the first place and for
me that is the real heart and soul of
Entrepreneurship and the fun of it is
making something from nothing because
you are resourceful right you look at
set of tools or a complete lack of tools
and you see something different right
like you see a little Gap and you're
able to pursue that and manifest
something in the world that otherwise
doesn't exist and the later stages are
amazing and there are people who are so
good at the later stages I not convinced
that I'm one of them but the early
chapters where at the time we're like
it's going to be great when at some
point I have X when at some point when I
cross my number which is a moving
goalpost right you cross like a million
and then you cross this and then you
cross this keeps moving that when I
think back to those early chapters I get
excited right it's like I remember how
unknown it all was too yeah and how fun
some of the unknowns were there were
definitely hard times there were all
sorts of difficult chapters that I'm
sure I've blocked out from my
memory but I wasn't frustrated earlier
at all I think it's just the juice of
thinking back to those very nent stages
that's my guess well it's also I think I
try to remind myself that a lot of my
Nostalgia is a liar oh totally I'm like
oh starting upso I would drink most of
the days which we were doing I was just
like drinking with Neville [__]
around getting some deals and and then
you remember like oh I felt lonely I
felt really insecure I felt for sure and
I guess I wonder is that something
you're exploring now what is that
creation or thing that you can bite into
yeah because that was something I was
wondering for you in that you know I've
obviously I've known you a long time I
remember it's funny when I'm doing this
whole book thing which I'm not talking
about what book's called um no no no no
no no no dude no one knows don't even
look it up and I think about you cuz I
think that guy [__] worked hard yeah
I remember you working hard and it made
me wonder where you're at today because
I I see you not chasing I think in my
older age we're both in our early 40s
I'm I think I was chasing a lot like I
want to get famous or I want to get
money and yeah and then I I like I
wonder not what you're chasing anymore
but like what you're enjoying or what
you're not after is the right word and
not what's next but I'm noticing oh
Tim's not really going
aggressive on YouTube and chasing what
other people are doing and it's not just
YouTube but I like I wonder how he's
evaluating things I think to your point
of nostalgia being a liar often times
right where we have this rose-colored
picture of the past if I look at the
chapters around say the beginning of the
4our work week 4our body
Etc I was very hungry I was moving very
quickly and certainly using processes
and Automation and so on
but there was a lot of uncertainty and I
would say that as I
have prioritized mental health and just
overall well-being which includes
physical but at the time I was in
physical prime condition I mean I was in
very good shape I was still competitive
in sports I would say that looking back
a lot of those Adventures were formative
and I enjoyed them but I in retrospect
should have enjoyed them more for what
they were which like these seminal
moments right
and I think part of what you're reading
in me in terms of less chasing is
that I feel like and I suspect many
people feel like you know the dog that
catches the car or the Greyhound that
catches the mechanical rabbit and you're
like this is what I was
chasing it's good [__] that's funny like
it's kind of like tragic comic but which
is not to diminish money it's not to
diminish financial success it's I think
easyer for us to to have these
conversations because there's a degree
of security and and stability and
comfort yes right so it's not to
diminish any of that cuz I know what it
feels like to be like [__] like I'm not
sure what I'm going to do about
Healthcare next month I'm not sure what
I'm going to do about this next month I
know what that can feel like and it's
not a good feeling eating from Jack In
The Box I remember eating so many meals
from Jack In The Box on Shoreline across
the street from my shitty apartment with
my terrible roommate who just ditched
and like almost got all my stuff yanked
because there were all these eviction
notices like I remember those days I
don't want to return to those days but
having caught the thing that I was
chasing I've
realized that none of these targets are
panaceas right they're kind of
placeholders to keep you
motivated and I've also if if you look
at patterns in my life I tend to do
things if I'm going to do something well
seems to be in the 5 to 10 year range
books start up investing predominantly I
focused on from say 2008 to
2015 and then I published this blog post
on taking a long startup vacation and
stopped that categorically I stopped
doing it completely for a period of time
because the game got saturated it got
more complicated much more competive
ative much riskier from a term's
perspective so I stopped and then you
have podcasting I'm coming up on 10
years next
April and it's a good time to pause and
reflect
and I feel like podcasting also and I
will have questions for you about
YouTube because I go back and forth on
my thoughts on YouTube but when I see
best
practices merge or converge maybe is is
a better way to put it with a lot of the
algorithm driven growth SL lack of
growth that we
see I really want to step back and see
if I am in a position where I'm uniquely
differentiated or have some type of
competitive Advantage not because I care
about competition per se but it's like
am I in a red ocean that used to be a
blue ocean right or am I developing
practices that are are going to lead me
to a point of not just uniformity with
others but like are we all running
towards a cliff like a bunch of lemmings
in the sense that for instance email I'm
going all over the place I realized but
like no no no this is great with like
email blog especially if you're open
source like I'm based on WordPress you
effectively own your audience right you
don't own your audience you have a
direct relationship with your audience
your audience is portable okay if you're
on a platform that includes almost any
platform there's some some technical
work arounds for these things but you
are renting your audience and so I've
seen multi-million doll Facebook pages
back in the day when that was a huge
thing get turn off just like pg& might
turn off your power during a rolling
blackout in California it's like one day
you're on and you have employees and a
big business the next day you are turned
off yeah and I've seen that over and
over again I've seen for instance
organic reach get throttled now you have
to pay I think it's foolish to assume
that can't happen to whatever platforms
you're using today and as we've seen a
number of precipitating events Co for
instance the writer strike another
example drive people to what they've
realized can be a profitable model in
the form of podcasting
YouTube as the mimicry of Tik Tok has
engendered a drive to video and short
form video I feel like I have fewer and
your
um differentiators and
advantages and the human basis of
recommendation has been replaced by in
large part kind of top- down corporate
directives and
algo modifications right so I
feel like I'm in a transitional period
right now
potentially where I'm I'm taking my foot
off the gas CU I'm not sure the car is
going in a direction where I want to
take it to 120 on the Autobon you know
yeah so that's where I am
and I'm also not in a rush because maybe
it's just fatigue frankly I mean like I
started the podcast 10 years ago and
there are people with Incredible
longevity and not very many but like
Rogan as an example I mean the guy's a
machine and he's very good at what he
does 10 years is also a long time for me
right that's a long time to do one thing
consistently I'm going to continue doing
the podcast but from a growth
perspective I feel like YouTube is
probably one of the more appealing
avenues for growth
currently but offsetting that is a
desire to increasingly be less
publicly visually recognized because
there are compromises that I've made
related to that there are safety issues
there are privacy issues there's lots of
weird stuff that happens I'm not sure I
want to actually I'm quite sure I do not
want to make my face more recognizable
on the counterargument side I know we're
going all over the place no dude by the
way this is fire okay good this is fire
keep going I want to know on the
counterargument side and this is both a
reason not to do YouTube but also a
reason maybe I'm over evaluating the
risks and I've talked to some folks I
don't want to name them but very
well-known iconic writers photographers
creators who did one thing very very
well one thing which also makes me
question sort of the Jack of all trades
approach that I
think is in some respects a norm now
where you're present
and growing on many many different
formats but putting that aside for a
second the halflife of Fame I think is
going to drop
precipitously as algorithm chasing
becomes more and more dominant and more
and more determinant of what is surfaced
in the sense that I would be shocked if
there's ever again someone as dominant
as say Oprah
was for effectively let's just call it
who knows a third to a half of all the
women in the United States right one
person one
show the sort of long taale of
personalization I think has largely
removed that possibility
and if you even think about like the
personal halflife which I think we can
extract like studying the micro to to
study the macro because the macro can
seem super intimidating and abstract and
ungraspable if you just think about your
personal experience and I've talked to
friends about this 10 years ago if you
got sent some crazy video from friends
like that video would stick around for a
while right it might be the video that
sticks around for like a week oh my god
do you see that crazy video of the thing
how many of those do you get per day now
right something that would win the gold
medal of the meme Olympics crushes all
the stupid things that you would have
looked at 10 years ago infinitely more
attention grabbing and the halflife is
what 30 seconds 60 seconds so I think
Fame as a phenomenon in most
cases online will have a very very short
halflife and that worries me a bit from
a psychological adaptive perspective
because I think that
means that has Supreme implications for
the sort of dopamine hit like rat
stepping on a cocaine
pedal aspect of content creation right
like if what you do is less and less
persistent meaning it has less and less
durability like what game are you
signing up for mhm and what does winning
that game look like these are really
critical questions right okay yeah we're
all playing games right now like Beyond
food shelter a handful of things at the
lower rungs of Mel's hierarchy of needs
we're all playing games like what games
you playing
and just as important like what does
winning that game or those games look
like and is that the life you
want and so looking at how things are
developing and maybe this is a very
fancy way of rationalizing just
being older and more fatigued I don't
know but I find where things are
trending super super
worrisome so if I could be long a number
of things I'd be like okay mental health
Therapeutics
dialysis which seems pretty dystopian
but like I would be bury long those
things I think we haven't even seen a
glimpse of some of the mental health
challenges that are on the horizon
so probably a long answer to a very
short question but that informs I think
a certain it's not just calmness
although there's a lot that goes into
that on my side compared to my earlier
self but
a not wanting to rush into committing at
high
speed in certain directions that are
very appealing right now at face value
I'm like you know what if you have here
we go I'm going to shut the [__] up in a
second it's like if here's the thing if
I think about the authors I respect the
most if I think about the filmmakers I
most aspire to be like or admire the
most they're not playing a volume game
right like Miyazaki who just put out I
think it's the boy in the Heron the
Japanese name is like how do you live
it's a totally different name but they
put out great work that is uniquely
their own you watch that movie and if
you've seen other Studio ji Miyazaki
movies you're like that is the signature
that could not be anyone other than
Miaki right you see like a Daniel de
Lewis film there's so many examples of
this these people have unique
capabilities they've harnessed they
don't need to rush right so if I find
myself feeling compelled to rush either
it's a false signal I should ignore or
I'm about to do something that a lot of
other people could
do and that for me is a cue to really
chill the [__] out and be like wait wait
a second let me go back let me read Blue
Ocean strategy let me go back let me
read 820 principle let me go back and
read any number of things I mean I do
like reading let me go back and watch
these following documentaries about
people who really took an unorthodox
path okay and then let me sit down and
ask why do I feel like I
am compelled to
rush
so there have it wo that was one that
was [__] fire thanks this has been on
my mind nonstop for the last couple of
months I think people confuse in action
with patience okay tell me more what I
heard and I'm curious how you approach
it is that instead of rushing really
quickly you're understanding yourself
and thinking
patiently okay what is my right play for
me to move and I think in the past you
know maybe you can revisit is okay let's
go rush and find things and maybe stuff
will happen but now you're like like
you're observing yeah you sound calm
you're thinking about what's happening
where my advantages what's going on and
where is a place that you frankly want
to play and instead of rushing into
let's say YouTube World which does feel
like a lot of people are rushing into
these kind of things M really thinking
about what your play is I love that I I
guess the question I was curious about
there is how do you what is your
approach for thinking about what's
underserved because what you said I
thought it's [__] powerful it's like
you can put effort but in the wrong
thing when you did your book you're like
oh blogging is it and then your second
book podcasting is it how are you
approaching thinking about getting to
like even now you're like all right I
like podcast I'm doing
podcast yeah I love doing the podcast I
love doing the podcast it's going to get
a lot harder as a business it is already
be look what do you mean by that well
I'm very fortunate in the sense that and
this was not accidental right like this
podcast is intended to
be long form thoughtful
dense and Incredibly practical tactical
right and I'll mention it because you've
been very good at receiving feedback but
million dollar weekend we are going to
get to it and talk about very practical
steps all of this is practical though if
if you look at it through the lens of
making decisions this has been
positioned as high Ultra Premium right
as far as podcast go advertisers
audience right we've done all the
polling and so on so it's like if you
want to reach Ted this is the podcast
right if you want to hit millions or or
at least let's just say thousands of
very very well-known creators with one
podcast like this is the podcast so the
premium positioning means that like for
the next year we're basically already
sold out with advertising right so I'm
in a very good position but I think
overall this is true on YouTube too
but and it relates to everything I just
said it is going to get and is getting
harder to differentiate right like back
when I had like Jamie Fox and Arnold S
on podcast that that was insane blew
people's minds right that was just not
something that really happened and now
that you have incredibly talented people
comedians entertainers writers right
that's why I mentioned the writer strike
earlier who for a period of time did not
have the option of doing what they
normally do and they dip their toe into
podcasting they dip their toe into
YouTube and they're like wow actually
I'm really good at this and I can get
paid
interesting there are exceptional
exceptionally skilled people producing
things for podcast and YouTube what I'm
saying is the bar for Quality has gone
up dramatically in all of these areas
but the possibility for originality I
would say has diminished as a result of
the sheer volume of entrance so in terms
of thinking about like what's unserved
yeah I would say that I'm looking for a
ven diagram if you ask any of the
questions I'm asking myself in isolation
which I've done in the past you can lead
yourself to bad decisions so if you ask
yourself what can I uniquely do and
that's your question and you use that to
determine what you do you can end up
doing things that you dislike that are
draining that don't have any type of
Market fit whatsoever so that's not
enough right although for me that is
necessary like what am I uniquely suited
to do because that will give me not
only an immediate say first mover or
early mover Advantage it gives me
endurance so so being uniquely suited to
something doesn't mean that you are the
only person that can do it maybe you
just love it more right like with me and
language learning is an example now
that's not a business I mean it did lead
to me being one of the First Investors
in Du linga so that worked out but I
have infinite endurance for that in a
way that most people don't that's a huge
Advantage even though other people could
technically do it right so there's what
am I uniquely suited for what do I find
easy that other people find hard right
then there's what is underserved but if
you approach that by itself you can make
some really bad decisions and I've done
that in the past like what do people
need now I'm not the boss of myself I've
turned my audience into the boss of me
this is also how people get shaped in
horrifying Ways by social media or their
audiences on YouTube right your most
extreme behaviors get
reinforced so you repeat those you
exaggerate them and your stage Pres your
social media presence becomes you this
is really important you have to be
careful about the masks you wear because
you will become those masks and I've
seen that like I'm sure you've met
people
like it's terrifying you will be shaped
by your audience and by these creative
decisions so not just asking what is the
unmet need but a question I might ask is
like what experiments can I
run that I think will meet the needs
intended by say the podcast in a
different way and also I mean another
question that I ask is like instead of
like what is the new new thing like what
is something
old that is being neglected doesn't have
to be new by the way right so for
instance that led me to start five
bullet Friday in the newsletter ages ago
because people are like email's dead
nobody's going to use email anymore
email's dead you hear that every year
and that was particularly true when I
launched F at Friday because it's was
like social media
Snapchat ah young kids are never going
to use email and I was like well it's
true until they get a job and then guess
what they're going to use email and so
in that particular case I wasn't looking
for the new new thing I was looking for
something old that was kind of neglected
and I wanted to also own my audience so
that led to you know millions of people
for the newsletter so those are some of
the questions that I ask I think I've
learned for me personally I make better
decisions when it's a bit of a vent
diagram if I go after any one of those
which could include profit by the way
that's one that gets people boy oh boy
and I've I've succumbed to that too
right if you're like what has the most
leverage for Revenue profit Etc yeah
that can lead you in directions that end
up compromising well-being end up
compromising long-term growth end up
compromising fil in the blank personal
and professional and organizationally
speaking so anyway someone said to me
recently like don't trade your 9 to5 for
a 24/7 yeah and it's like that the cool
part about entrepreneurship is that you
can create a life you want whether you
want to live in Austin you want to live
in Spain you want to live wherever Tokyo
yeah but it's then are you actually
living a life you want yeah yeah yeah
yeah one common one question I love that
you said experiments that was you know
kind of super early for you and how you
developed a lot of your stuff and I
think for a lot of people it's like oh
well I got to make this big decision
it's like well how can you test it right
now how can you test it for really cheap
how can you test it and see if that's
actually the case mhm so I love that you
said that the other thing I was curious
when's the last time you read for our
work week you were talking about books
you read that you come back to I was
like I wonder you know sometimes we come
back to our own things for sure I was
looking at 4 Hour a couple weeks ago
actually yeah because my books I make I
mean they reflect things that I am doing
and have done but they also act as
references for me like I go back to the
4our chef all the time for various
things like 4our body I go back to it
all the time for various things and for
our work week in this particular case
because I'm thinking about virtual
assistants which have
really uplevel in the last handful of
years with technology and also different
companies and types of training I've
been thinking again about virtual
assistance so I wanted to revisit like
scripts principles Etc because I've
shifted from vas to inperson full-time
work chart type stuff and I'm
experimenting again I have a full-time
VA also on the payroll now and I wanted
to
revisit some of what worked in the past
because very often the things that
worked then are still going to work and
the principles are the principles for a
reason right the tactics the tools the
platforms the hardware devices those all
change but in terms of human
communication Clarity lack of clarity
the words are still words yeah and so I
wanted to revisit some of that so as an
example I mean I've been thinking about
going back to text I've been thinking
about going back to blog posts it's so
Antiquated it's so out of fashion and
it's so high labor too I mean because
that is something where I do not feel
comfortable
delegating if I'm putting my name to
something I want to be the one who put
those words on paper or on a screen in
this case but I've thought about it I've
thought about it quite a bit show and
we'll see we'll see I mean that's a
heavy lift it is a heavy lift
but that's also something I want to be
aware of or cognizant of and that is am
I doing this because it fits into the V
ven diagram or am I doing it because it
requires less work because requiring
less work does not automatically mean
elegant combination of things that leads
to my goals right and if you don't have
those kpis like you mentioned watch out
for vanity metrics too right like okay
this matters why does that matter
because it leads to this okay why does
that matter why does it because of this
okay because of this and ultimately it's
going to come down to all right you want
this amount of money okay why do you
want that money because I want to trade
it for this experience or this
possession okay why do you want those
because you want this feeling okay well
let's keep that in mind yeah you want to
sleep well at night don't do all this
other [__] that is going to cause you
anxiety can I highlight what they can I
yeah of course so two parts one I want
to shout out for people looking for VAs
yeah the site I use is hire mymom.com
really yeah okay all right amazing so
hire mymom.com I'm not affiliated no
cuts no nothing they can sponsor my
podcast or Tim's podcast uh but you
basically it's moms who want to spend
time with their kids that are super
Elite moms uhhuh and they just don't
want to work fulltime though yeah and so
you can B get these super impressive
parents at pretty affordable prices so I
hired someone recently was the executive
assistant for the Dallas Stars the
hockey team oh wow okay right she has
two kids she wants to stay at home she
did quit last
week telling you real she quit but but
it's like you're finding that level of
caliber at I'll say CU she's not working
she was 30 bucks an hour which is insane
yeah you know for someone who's a really
impressive woman why she quit she is an
executive assistant and she thought I
was asking to do some assistant level
work so I asked her to schedule some
appointments I asked her to make some
purchases and she's like I just want to
do the business work and so I really
admire and respect when people know what
they want I I was a little frustrated
cuz like you quit all of a sudden
abruptly send me a voluntary termination
letter I've never received one of those
ever but she's professional you know but
you go back to it and and that's part of
business I think a lot of people do once
and then they you know it doesn't work
it's like yeah that's part of business
it's like okay I'm going to go and find
another one and improve my process to
understand like hey in the hiring
process here you're going to have to
purchase something from a store is that
is that going to bother you great
doesn't okay we can move you forward my
recommendation there yeah especially if
you're considering a full-time higher
yeah test them for a few months and have
them do that stuff because people know
how to interview and a lot of people
will say absolutely no task to small no
problem and that's horseshit in the same
way if they say they're going to buy
whatever you're offering ask them to pay
you yeah then you know then you know
it's real so yeah if you can try before
you buy especially on the eav
hiring in general make them do some of
the grunt work not grunt work but just
smaller things and by the way like
anyone who's got real chops right it's
kind of like John Paul deer like putting
the lotion on your hands right like that
guy has done every job he's done every
job and you want someone with that same
type of ethos yeah right we will almost
every person absum is a contractor to
start yeah and even with my YouTube
channel I'm going to pay you to do your
trial video great you can see if you
like me maybe you hate me maybe I don't
like you maybe we do like each other but
you're at least getting paid so there's
not really as much downside for both of
us yeah the other thing I thought was
really cool is looking back on our old
lives that you said like looking back in
your old work I used to live in this
really 800t shitty house and I went back
at it and then I also look back on my
photos every month I do a month review I
look back on my photos and it's it's
nice to look where we've been and where
we are I do a month review you can
literally just scroll up on your phone
go to your photo scroll up really far
and almost every time you're pretty
proud of where you are are now so those
times were're frustrated yeah I went
back to that old house and I felt wow
man I'm so proud of where I am now but I
didn't really always notice that I do
but going back there helped that for
sure if you're used to looking ahead
right all forward yes and you've
developed a certain set of habits and
attributes being in sixth
year always being in the fast lane it is
a practice to augment that with other
abilities 100% right this is why a lot
of people self-destruct when they quote
unquote retire right if they're trying
to go from like autobond to park it's
like well hold on maybe we should get
used to some other
gears let's see what happens so let's
talk about tests let's talk about
experiments let's talk about small steps
million dollar weekend number one what
is the well here let's do the subtitle
the surprisingly simple way to launch a
7 figure business in 48 hours so for
people who find this tantalizing
I guess number one why should they
believe it let's start there yeah like
why the [__] should they listen because
they're going to come across a lot of
promises a lot of clickback on YouTube
and then they click on they're like oh
come
on so why should they believe it maybe
there's a case study or two or example
you could share and then if somebody
wants to test drive something from this
podcast like are there things they can
do 100% I've come up with simple rule
because what's crazy on YouTube and
podcast now you can make whatever title
up you want yeah people saying oh I'm
worth 100 million oh my really you can
just write that yeah and so don't trust
any
author that has gotten Rich from their
any business author I would say that's
gotten Rich from their book or their
course yep I think that's a prettyy
straight forward approach like if that's
how they got rich teaching you how they
got rich like double check who they are
and maybe look for someone else that's
maybe I worked for Zuckerberg help start
mint.com help start kick flip.com I help
start cit.com somebody who has a very
well Grim mustache
my Latino girlfriend loves the mustache
I don't normally like it but she's like
you got to keep that I was like yes baby
see see and running appsumo decom and so
you can I'm not getting rich on the book
and I think that's a very simple test to
think about who you want to listen to
specifically in business yep agreed and
secondly can you see their businesses MH
a lot of times like oh I've got these
businesses you'll never see it though
why not because you can't know about it
why not yeah you never get to the answer
that's probably why you don't ever have
them on your shows yeah I'll just give
you a case study of Jake so Jake lives
up north Texas he's got three kids got a
day job and he's had dreams just like a
lot of people have had and he's had it
for 2 years mhm I was like Jake how do
we change you in in 48 hours because
everyone has a weekend and now I'm about
to have a family and I'm realizing like
family YouTube book prioritizing my
partner and our kid like it's hard to
have time to start a s hustle it's hard
to have time to like get going the
reality though is we do all have
weekends mhm we have 52 of them so we
can do something in a weekend even if
it's really small action and by the way
it doesn't have to be a millionaire in a
weekend it's through every weekend you
can pound it over some time it can get
there now the things that people can do
in a weekend right now right this is the
thing with books I think your book is
phenomenal if everyone gets two books
it's yours for a work week and million
dollar weekend your book has such a
great recipe such a great recipe but
what I noticed when I've worked through
my course which I'm not going to call it
I've worked through a course 10,000
people have gone through it YouTube
channel millions of people you can give
them the recipes but they still may not
do something and I was kind of like what
the [__] is going on
right like you have a big dream you have
a dream like hey I want to work here I
want to make a thousand bucks a month I
want grocery money I want whatever it is
but then you haven't done nothing for
two years like Jake and the reality is
that most people are afraid of starting
mhm they're not ready they feel they're
not ready they're actually all ready
there's a lot of rich people who are
really ordinary I think people think
it's all like oh no I grew up in Sila
Valley and Tim did these things it's
like no there's a lot of really normal
people that are rich but they all got
started and we got started over and like
how many times you did brain Quicken
you've done all these things opening the
kimono
yeah yeah you've done a lot of things
and so how do we overcome the fear of
starting then you can do that right now
that's why I asked people and we did it
earlier do the dollar challenge just get
a dollar right now just go get going
right now MH and we surveyed just like
you did with your book and the number
one takeaway from the book by far was
now not how I was like what do you mean
n how they're like yeah no you always
just do right now I'm like what do you
mean just right [__] now yeah what's
the smallest action you can take that
will get you momentum so you want to be
a content creator post a video right now
with your phone my first YouTube video
was with my phone mhm just shirtless in
my little house 800t house you say
shirtless yeah yeah it's not impressive
it wasn't like ripped shirtless it was
just like sweaty just got off a bike in
my Spandex I actually just watched the
video a few weeks ago cuz I was like is
this true and I was like wow really it's
on the channel yeah and now my videos
are you know give or take around 35
$30,000 to make per video wow from all
the salaries my God but that was a short
listing with an iPhone 10 that everyone
can do right now my most popular YouTube
video of all time and we're sitting here
with like pretty nice video set up got a
basically a studio the whole n yards my
most popular YouTube video of all time
is me in my kitchen somebody with like
God knows what kind of old phone the
resolution is terrible deshelling
hard-boiled eggs without peeling that is
my that is my most successful YouTube
video of all
time a bit sad about that given how much
effort goes into other things but yeah
yeah dude I mean one of your favorite
videos of mine is microwaving eggs yeah
we talked about last I love microwaves
and I love microwaving my eggs
sometimes I use a stove my girlfriend's
like let's use a stove baby all right
see so what can we do right now let me
give you a great example as well I'm a
big pin baller mhm so I have two pinball
machines at home and this morning
literally I was watching how to make a
pinball machine by Godzilla it's the
number one rated pinball machine in the
world sick that's what I have at home
and you know when most people think I
want to start a pinball business what do
they think holy [__] I've got to been to
this machine I've got to go figure out
software I've got to do oh I got to
probably get a website maybe on Shopify
shout out Shopify they sponsor your
podcast which you'll eventually need
maybe I need a lawyer because I've got a
patent idea and then that's 6 months 12
months two years of nothing yeah now
what's crazy Stern Pinball the number
one maker of pinball machines they put
out this video behind the scenes of
Godzilla they literally took like a
board and then bent some metal and just
kind of threw the ball mhm you can do
that right now you could do that in one
day and go to people literally on your
phone in person hey working on this
pinball machine let me show you to you
right now and see what you think and you
could get people to purchase your Pinal
machine before you spent 6 months 6
years doing nothing yeah same thing with
the cybertruck six years and barely it's
getting delivered and so there's things
that people can start realizing let me
actually see if people really want this
and find out right away so that that's
really around surprisingly simple it's
like there's business models there's all
these things you can do it's like well
if I only have a weekend and I don't
have a lot of time how do I break it
down to the essence of the simplest form
and so in terms of the book where I
think the a lot of the breakthroughs
happen is how do I get going right now
like with the pinball machine or with
Jake Jake had a dream to do golf trips
mhm he wants to do golf trips like super
bougie high-end I do golf I'm golf I
have golfed I wouldn't say I golf yeah I
don't golf I like dis golf M you know
dis golf yeah like I'm I'm a cyclist but
he wants to do golf trips and so he's
been thinking about it's one of these
people I'm sure you've noticed them they
like talk to you about a dinner they're
like oh man I hate my job but I'd like
to try this and so it's like all right
we have 48 hours Jake how do we actually
do right now to see if other people want
golf trips that's what you think is a
problem MH now I think the best problems
in business are your own yeah I agree
like your show really I mean if you
think about it's you getting to talk to
people you want that's what it is that's
a problem you have about learning
different areas business science Health
Fitness and then you publish it and make
a lot of money doing that like how cool
is that best job ever dude it's a sweet
work it's super sweet so in terms of the
book it's one how do we just get going
[__] right now right now and then
giving people more momentum stories
actions like the dollar challenge now
not how uh Freedom number which is
understanding what is the number you
need to quit your job mhm for me it was
3,000 do you have a number oh yeah
slightly different moniker but same idea
like Target monthly income which was not
just the replacement it was a bit more
part of this exercise called dreamlining
but oh yeah yeah exactly but very
similar idea totally we like figure out
the basic math because maybe you need
less very often you need less than you
think you need I live in Barcelona I
think our apartment's $1,000 yeah it's
not huge to be clear but it's like you
can live a lot cooler life than you
think for a lot more affordable than you
realize yeah so part one is around that
and then again we can get into the
recipe and I think you know the four
work recipe is fire you know I shout out
you in the book and and honor how you
approach it and that as one way but even
before that it's how do you understand
the upside of asking and how do you
become an asking machine how do you
build an asking muscle yeah so what did
Jake do so Jake I mean first off we did
the coffee challenge so we drove over to
Taco Deli and I was like all right Jake
Let's go ask for 10% off he's like ah he
just done sales before he's like it's
easy easy it's always easy until you do
it and then guess what it's not as hard
as he thinks and that that's really true
for a lot of life we're afraid of things
almost every time we Face the hard thing
yeah it's never as hard as we thought
like iasa for me yeah part of it I was
so afraid and thank you for giving me
time and coaching me around it before I
went in but a lot of iasa was just like
facing something hard more than all the
other stuff for me it felt so
challenging and being able to overcome
it same thing with the coffee challenge
just go do it today commit to do it
right now for yourself so Jake did it
bam just to be clear I wouldn't do the
uh take iasa today as a translation no
no no I would say the coffee challenge
coffee challeng coffee challenge then
Jake did the dollar Challenge and he was
so nervous but then he was like wow I
haven't done [__] in two years in
literally in like six hours he already
had a lot of momentum now the once you
kind of get practice on those different
things really the book breaks down in
two parts which is how do you build and
find something that people are excited
to give you money for now that you're
better at starting and asking all right
let me start swinging MH so it's
thinking about okay how do I come up
with ideas how do I see if there's a
million dollar in money I can make on it
check out a one minute business model
the third part grow it is like finding
social media for customers email to
actually as you were saying sell them
and communicate with them and then the
growth machine which is the Playbook I
use at mint.com and abs.com my YouTube
the book it's the same marketing
Playbook I use over and over these are
all things by the way people were like I
want it more complicated and I need it's
like it's 48 hours and you know this
like by having these limitations
bringing out a lot more creativity
bringing out a lot more resourcefulness
I would go so far as to say like this is
going to be a broad statement but like
the the best
creativity comes from constraints like
you need constraints those sound bad
they sound like restraints like you're
strapped into you know electroshock
therapy or something but you need
constraints and weekend is a constraint
less than $100 is a constraint x two
hours is a constraint these will all 4
Hour Work week four hour work week like
these right which is it's a constraint
it's a constraint and how is it an
advantage I think most people think I
don't have money it's like that's a
great thing okay what do you do now that
you don't have money yeah okay how can
you make it happen and then you realize
like oh maybe there's something here for
the just like a pinball machine which is
crazy like no you need to build an
engineer no take a piece of wood Bend
some metal see if you can get a three I
generally say three people in the
weekend if you can get three customers
to me that's validation meaning that
this is something you can invest in mhm
that's it you can do that in 48 hours
and I think people give themselves so
much time and so many excuses that's why
the book starts with frequently made
excuses yeah frequently made excuses
yeah to be able to get them past that so
they can get going on their Journey yeah
totally and there's so many examples of
low stakes
lowcost say prototyping right I'll just
mention one guy people can look him up
Stephen key fascinating guy and he has
licensed tons of toys to huge
manufacturers and so his game is
licensing right he's not actually in the
venturing business he's not in the
manufacturing and the distribution
business he comes up with ideas he like
this is a great game and he sells it to
Hasbro or whoever it might be these huge
companies he uses construction paper
some glue Scotch tape he'll prototype it
take some photos of how it might work
and then off off to the race as he goes
and he just does that over and over and
over and over again there's a lot of
examples of this like Airbnb 60 billion
10000 billion doll company that
literally started in a weekend they
posted to some design conference like
hey we have a couch does anyone want it
yeah there wasn't some fancy website
there was no Mark andreon funding there
was none of that and now that's a
hundred billion dollar business yeah so
the thing that we talked about a long
time ago is that you only need to get
lucky once yeah but to get lucky you
have to be doing things consistently
every single weekend to eventually get
to that point and I think people miss
out on that so once Jake had a little
bit of of movement yeah right so Taco
Deli Etc yeah what happens then doesn't
need to be Jake but like for someone
like let's let's break it down I think
the more concrete tactical I know that
we both appreciate so now it's like okay
well what do I sell yeah there's a lot
of different ways I'll just give you one
literally just just make a list of your
day do breakfast lunch dinner and try to
write everything that sucked MH so for
you right now you've already told me one
finding a VA EA yeah yeah opportunity
mhm Jake his different ones he has kids
so toys he found it really annoying to
that his kids get older now to find toys
he's like ah [__] I need to get rid of
these toys and get new ones maybe
there's a toy rental business oh it's
kind of cool well I mean look at chag
for textbooks right huge business shag
for toys doesn't exist yeah so someone
does that sry he didn't end up doing it
but it was going through different proc
s that he was excited to solve for
himself he had a coffee problem and what
he stumbled upon is that he went on a
golf trip with guys mhm a year ago and
he was like I really love that I want
more of that in my life I want to have
something to look forward to on my
calendar mhm I was like and I didn't
want him to do that business I wanted to
do the toy rental so one additional
approach I'll throw in there because
it's actually how I started brain Qui
you the first business Sports Nutrition
Etc which is where I cut my teeth for
all the things I followed but I as part
of my calculus I went through all my
credit card statements and at the time I
was making I don't know like base salary
was 40 Grand a year in the Bay Area
during like one of the peak rushes it
was partially explains why I was eating
Jag in the Box um like with California
taxes and like rent and it was like gone
before you know it so I went through my
credit card statements and I looked at
what I spent a lot of money on like what
did I spend a lot of money on
disproportionate to my income right
that's fire and that's how I landed on
Sports Nutrition in part I also had some
knowledge around it and and the ability
to to find people involved with that
but another approach I've heard from
several different entrepreneurs who
ended up building huge businesses is
they looked at where they were cobbling
together Solutions like where are they
paying for multiple things or using
multiple things to M some half-ass
solution to a problem that they have
yeah opportunity right yeah another
another one I've liked and to be clear
you can have that and then still there's
no business there so we did that we
tried to compete with clavio in
e-commerce and we were cobbling together
Sol I don't know what they do MailChimp
or convert kit but just for e-commerce I
see mhm and so we Cobble together a
solution and we're like oh we could sell
this to people and then when we tried to
sell it no one wanted to buy it yeah and
that's what we get to later in the book
and so I think the other comment I would
actually highlight that it's great you
called it out is what's on your to-do
list that you're just avoiding doing MH
that is actually a really interesting
business so for you you're too list is
to find an EA what else is on your to-do
list that's maybe been there over 2
weeks that's a good one let me think
about that for a second I can tell you
one of mine yeah let's do one of yours
[__] dude I need a house manager mhm
yeah I need someone to just handle
property stuff my painting fell my grass
died because I put my car over it it
didn't get watered I have a coal plunge
that needs to get refilled and I have my
girlfriend who's pregnant so I'm taking
care of her and prioritizing her I don't
have time to even find the house manager
so there's one so in the case of if a
better example exists that we want to
run with but since we've introduced Jake
yeah we sck with Jake and we can also do
the VA one but Jake's thing was I wanted
to do golf let's stick with that next up
is it a million dollars of money that
you can make in that so how big is the
market over what period of time a year
or what period of time I'm more just
looking at the market I'm not necessar
looking at a time frame on that it's
just like are there people now today
that at least a million dollars what's
crazy is app suuma
success I would say significantly
because the market just grew we chose a
great Market yeah right when I started
abing there was 10 software products now
there's at least 10,000 software
products if not more and so we chose the
right market so with Jake he was
basically there's two ways you can do it
one just look at Google Trends which is
super basic everyone most people know
this like is Google Trends is a flat the
cining is it growing and look at it
relatively in terms of Search terms for
like yeah go to trends. google.com and
just double check it and this is similar
almost identical to the blog post we had
it's just been evolved on your blog on
ver blog for our work week.com and then
the second part is all right is there a
million people or not even a million
people how many people and how much do
they spend on this same thing with
Chihuahuas Y how many people have
chihuaha how much do they spend on
Chihuahuas so for Jake it's how many
people are golfing how much do they
spend on Golf and can you get any other
data points but that's probably the most
straightforward way because again we
only do it in a weekend to see is there
at least a million dollars in there golf
is a billion dollar industry y multiple
billions of dollars so you can look at
the clubs you can look at things but
simplest way to do it go on Facebook
search do an ad how many people are
searching Golf and then you can Google
how much do people spend on golf a year
okay is there at least a million dollars
in there I can make in it I would
imagine that this point too I'm just
throwing this out there but that some of
these tools like chat jpt or Bard could
also be incredibly helpful 100% 100% how
much money do people spend on golf a
year how big is the market on golf you
could put that in right now and again
people are like well I need to do more
research it's like no we really just
want to understand like generally
because we only have a weekend yeah
otherwise that's the thing that like
okay two weeks four weeks six weeks 10
weeks and nothing's happened MH so next
up how do we actually understand what
the business model looks like again not
you know I went to Berkeley went to
Princeton like there's all these
complicated discounted cash flows you've
done a lot more investing than I have I
just want to know can I make a million
dollars in the business so the real
simplest business model one minute
Revenue cost expense divide that by a
million yeah and I have a bunch of
templates on the website but really
again I'm trying to understand is this
realistic trying to sell a business that
let's say a golf trip that's what he was
excited about $5,000 it's like 3,000 to
do it 2,000 can I sell this many golf
trips and how long will that take me mhm
and that would help him adjust the
business model like when I did Sumo
jerky and even when I've done appsumo I
had to do the same change when we did
appsumo I did bundles yeah remember I do
yeah cuz you productivity bundle you
helped put it on the map we did these
bundles and I was like dude I'm doing
[__] two months of work selling for
50 bucks I made $5 Andrew Chen came and
he's like a math genius and he's one of
my best friends he's like let's just do
this quick model and that's what we've
replicated stop doing bundles just do
one m and do one a week what's the
margin I went from $5 margin to $25
margin can you say that one more time so
let me back up so when you're doing
these quick models and again I don't
want people spend a lot of time people
like it's so simple I'm like that's the
point yeah by the way not to interrupt
but
like the vast majority of incredibly
profitable elegant
businesses are
simple yeah right yeah at their very
core they simple beautifully said at
their core like Google at its core I
know there there's a lot of complexity
that goes into delivering it but as a
business model very straightforward Uber
at its core very straightforward Airbnb
at its core very straightforward Patrone
right I mean like at their cores these
businesses are Geico even right like
very simple and you know I one thing I
want to take a step back on is
entrepreneurship is awesome it can
create a great life for you and that
doesn't mean you have to be a
millionaire that could be even grocery
money and I don't think people realize
they can change their life and have that
option like I was fired have you been
fired yeah from my first job fired ice
cream shop it's a long story you have to
like try to get fired there kind of
funny I mean my first job so the way
this guy was doing stuff the big boss I
was like 14 I don't even know if it was
legal but I was working at this ice
cream shop I was the cleaner so I was
cleaning the machines and doing this
that the other thing and the way that I
was taught to do it made absolutely no
[__] sense so I came up with my own
system for cleaning and I did it in like
one tenth the time the mistake I made
was I stayed at work for the rest of the
time and I read Black Belt Magazine and
I took the broom handle off of like one
of the mops and I practiced like karate
moves or something in the parking lot
and the boss understandably didn't find
that terribly inspiring and so he was
like I don't care if you already cleaned
it clean it again and I was like but
it's clean and that was early proof that
I'm effectively unemployable so yeah I
got fired I I'm sure maybe I got fired
from other stuff but I definitely got
fired from the first job I was trying to
wish I could see that dude I wish you
could have like some cameras that I
could see you with your broomstick
there's a good chance I had a rat tail
or a mullet too there's a very high
likelihood that I had a rat tiller amlet
at the time my point of going back and
what we'll stick with the Jake example
is that I was fired yeah and I was one
of the most traumatic moments of my life
mhm and then I was like I'm never
[__] again going to be dependent on
someone yeah ever [__] again yeah and
so I at that moment was very clear like
I want I need to get to my own level of
it's taken 30 years to it's Tak therapy
to work on it has I mean therapy has
been an amazing thing oh I get it I'm
laughing because also I get it yeah but
that was a realization that like one
person determined fade yeah I never
wanted that again yeah and so it doesn't
mean you have to quit like what's crazy
to have Sumo do we have a lot of people
with like really interesting side hustle
Amy does flowers she heads our customer
support Nick hads our growth he has a
teeth whitening Clinic amazing yeah om
man and his wife have a facial Clinic
I'm like it's kind of cool but at least
they have the option they seem to like
their jobs with that appsumo but they
have the option yeah that they can do
and that's why I do think people should
consider it no matter what they're doing
toally and it does take time to kind of
get to these places like I didn't my
first sell it up suuma was 12 bucks
yesterday was 200,000 but that did me
getting going be able to get and I'll
throw this in there too that much like
despite everything that I've said and
the freaking Ted Talk that I gave
earlier about all the things I'm
thinking about despite all of that I
still think everybody should start a
podcast
because you will learn a lot about
yourself and your own thinking you will
need to get better
communicating and there's a lot to be
taken from that even if you stop St it
after five episodes friend so I still
believe that for improving your ability
to communicate identifying verbal ticks
cleaning up your thinking by going
through that process makes it worth
starting podcast similarly I think
everybody should start a business does
not mean everybody should be a lifelong
entrepreneur right there are upsides to
9 to5 right like the ability to just
like turn off your work go home like
throw on the TV or watch some YouTube
and like have a couple beers with your
friends or family like there are are
arguments to be made that that in the
right circumstances yeah well dude like
Monday I'll tell you like Monday we have
a lawsuit because someone doesn't like
something two people are upset about
their salary that was Monday yeah right
right I'm just saying like there's
tradeoffs I was at this rock climbing
gym not too long ago last week actually
here in Austin a lot of good rock clim
gyms there's a new one Mesa Rim that is
much taller in terms of their top roping
areas than anything else I've seen here
in any case I was there and I saw this
woman cling and she had a shirt on that
said no Solutions only
tradeoffs and I looked at it and I said
okay maybe that doesn't make sense maybe
it's like Japanese billboard who knows
it like seems like English but it's not
quite like it's grammatical they're
English words but wait a second like
bear is the best friend wait a second
what does that mean that doesn't mean
anything but I sat with it and I was
like you know that's actually a very
healthy way to look at a lot of
decisions there is no one best like
there there are always trade-offs so
coming back to Jake Jake
and business model yeah how did you
tackle this and it can be Jake it can be
other examples but to the extent that
you can give real world examples so let
me give you two examples one Jake and
one you know very clear as well with
appsumo so Jake with Andrew Chen when he
came in and modified it so that was one
example the other example and I'll show
you there's dials you know kind of like
REM meets with your Finance dials
there's Revenue dials in your business
and so with Jake he was like I'm going
to do 10%
profit I was like okay hold on let's
just let's look at a one minute model
see what you can actually make and how
you can make a million dollars doing
this so we put it into the one minute
model and again it's very simple we
don't have a lot of time Revenue cost
profit so let's be specific Jake I was
like how much can people pay and again
let's just try to see what we can put
together as an offer that we'll bring to
people how much you pay on your golf
trip before I spent 2,000 what do you
think is reasonable for a 48 hour
amazing experience for people to go
golfing 4,000 great 4,000 now what are
the costs that go with that
do you have to play for travel no make
them pay for travel okay Hotel golf
whiskey cigars food great how much is
that and then we just real quick 2,000
bucks so your old model was like you
took a percentage but now we just do a
one minute model it looks like you make
like2 to $3,000 let's just call it 2500
per each golf trip mhm divide that by a
th000 that's not that many sales that
seems actually very doable to create a
million doll business just having golf
trips so just by understanding that it's
like okay cool we have an idea we like
we see that there's a million dollars
because a lot of times you're going to
work really hard in the wrong direction
or in a market that's really small and
you actually understand that this is a
business model relatively that can work
now we talked about Revenue dials let's
just say the average order value like
people are going to pay 1,000 holy [__]
that's never going to get there that's a
thousand people you're going to have to
sell is it a th yeah thousand people
that's a lot of people that's a lot so
if we can 5x that maybe we make it more
expensive can we get people to buy it
twice is there another types of products
and I I've written down the revenue
dollars in the book and there's free on
the website as well that you can be like
how can I change this model so that it's
easier to get to the million dollars so
people can find some of these resources
for free at million dooll weekend.com
totally mhm and now with that it was
like oh okay cool if it's $2,500 I don't
have to sell that many people to get to
a million dollar business now let me see
if I'm going to get even just three
customers today and I will tell you at
this point of the day Jake was really
frustrated because we had no sales he
just got to this you know we finished
this model and it's like [__] man like I
don't know like I don't know if this is
going to work and I think one of the
most powerful things you can do is go
for a walk and that's all we did I was
like Jake for two years you've thought
about this idea for two years you've
wondered what if and you want to be an
example to your kids and in 24 hours so
far you have an idea you have a business
model around it and now we can actually
find out if we can make a real business
out of this and I think that's just kind
of amazing for all of us like how can we
change our lives in a very quick amount
of time and give yourself a [__]
break if it's not immediately a million
dollars like go for a walk get a good
night's sleep go look at old photos to
realize how far we we've come yeah so
the next morning woke up and what we did
within I don't know an hour as he put
together with on a Google dock pictures
of a golf trip Golf Course food cigars I
don't know people do golfing clothing
polo
shirts and then a price 4,000 bucks
5,000 bucks and I was like all right
cool let's just call people so there's
three different validation methods to
see if people want to have a business
and number one is pre-selling this is
one of the most popular oh I see see if
people will purchase yeah so you have an
offer he literally put together a Google
doc cuz I do think it's nice when you
sell something that you can get people
like oh wow I can visualize it I can see
it same thing that elon's done with
cybertruck model 3 those are 6 years and
10 years before he actually delivered
mhm and he pre-old thousands tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of them
so it's a very effective model same
thing with airplanes hotels they all
pre-sale mhm to see if someone wants it
apartment buildings I mean we're looking
around here I mean the vast majority of
these were sold before construction was
finished certainly but often before
construction started 100% And when
you're doing businesses find a problem
you're excited about but as you said
with your stuff like if you only do that
and make sure that no one else wants it
you don't really have a business you
just have a hobby yeah so Jake has that
the other thing I think there's a super
common mistake for new entrepreneurs is
like well I want to do AI I'm like okay
have you done anything it's so funny I
was going to bring up this exact I love
yeahi I'm like have you used chat not
really have you coded anything no not at
all
woa what's your day job I'm in sales
okay what do you sell I sell solar very
okay maybe it's easier for us to start a
business selling and you can sell Ai and
do something within your zone of
influence and your zone of expertise
versus so far outside of it people make
it way more complicated on themselves
especially new entrepreneurs like What
are problems you like what are groups or
zones of influence you have yeah doesn't
mean you can't it just makes it so much
harder and so Jake he plays a lot of
golf I play no golf yeah he has a lot of
golf friends so the pre-sale method
makes he also knows how to find those
people right like he knows which
websites he goes to he knows which
celebrities he follows 100% he knows
where to go fishing for these people
100% And he has more credibility in
selling it too if he's like this is the
trip that I have always wanted to design
for myself there's a lot of weight
behind that when you're talking to
someone exactly yeah it was cool it was
cool to see him excited to create a
business around that and there's some
some mistakes that he ended up making
that others can avoid that I'll cover
but through that it was like all right
Jake you have a doc you got a model
let's contact these people let's just
call him right now you already practiced
it remember in the beginning we talked
about starting you got started let's
start asking and he called his brother
and people like n my brother like it's
too easy it should be easy M make it fun
like people no it's got to be hard I got
to make it challenging myself like why
why do you want to make it hard on
yourself what's the advantage in that
because that avoids you actually facing
reality yeah he calls a brother and
again we talked about that listen option
transition hey man I need feedback I'm
doing this process I'm trying to start a
business in a weekend do you remember
the golf trip one like yeah how did you
like it oh I liked it is there anything
you missed on it would you want to do it
again do you have another one scheduled
oh you don't oh so you're listening to
see if you what problems they have then
he provide an option hey I've got a golf
trip it's going to be in April it's
going to be to this place it's going to
be 5,000 bucks and it sounds like
something you'd be excited to do
Transition do you want to give me $100
right now as a deposit that's totally
refundable for this trip mhm and then
shut the [__]
up his brother sent him $100 right away
yeah okay brother fine easy Jake who
else have you golf with let's make a
dream 10 list of everyone you've ever
golfed with just 10 super easy this is
inspired by Chad Holmes so I got to give
him a shout out Ultimate Sales Machine
one of my favorite books all time and he
has a dream hundred I'm like 100's a lot
let's just do 10 only got a weekend so
then let's just go through your list who
else plays golf with you who else have
you gone on a trip with I went on a guy
named John calls up John and actually we
recorded the calls he's like yeah [__]
you John I'm like that's how you talk to
your friends but they're friends and
then he calls John he's like yeah man
can I just get your feedback because
again when you're selling you don't have
to make this big scary thing talk to
someone hey I'd love to get your
feedback this is what I'm working on is
that something you're interested in you
are okay cool do you want to give a
deposit to commit that you're actually
serious about doing it because a a
promise of a deposit is a rejection A
promise is a rejection hey yeah yeah
I'll do it just when you get closer
that's re that's actually a no yeah it's
a no you know this you've sold a lot
you've done a lot on this and so getting
them to actually tell you the truth with
their wallet and for me A lot of times
with rejection it's do I actually want
to do this business do I actually want
to make this thing possible and so it's
a test if you want something MH that's
it and so when you're getting rejected
be like like as I'm doing this book and
as I'm doing other things even with
asking people for on my YouTube videos
do I really want this I'm like [__] yes
I do do you want the thing that is being
rejected am I proud of what am I doing
like is this the thing I actually
believe I want to do yeah and that
rejection is just a test for yourself
and everyone can pass it's up for them
to choose yeah those are also like those
early rejections are valuable because if
your commitment starts to waver you're
still in the honeymoon
face it's only you are going to have
hard challenges you are going to have
hiccups later and if it's not going to
work like if you are going to waiver or
you might fold it's better to do it in a
sense super quick early than later and
you're really for me getting rejected is
an opportunity to learn and this is what
I do in sales I do this all the time hey
to this day I'll just say I just want to
learn and I frame it that's the first
phrase second phrase is you didn't want
this just tell me why not I want to
learn mhm people will reply and they'll
tell you really yeah they just do it
yeah you know I don't people are like no
I won't want to tell this person why not
and a lot of times after they say why
they didn't do something you can answer
that question and sell them
again so Jake called John he makes fun
of this guy so forth and then
hey man I have an idea this golf trip I
love your feack what do you think about
dude that sounds awesome yeah it's in
April you want to do a deposit another
deposit mhm and then he ended up getting
I believe five deposits within 48 hours
for 500 bucks yeah and then he also had
a partnership with another guy that he
went on a trip with and now 3 weeks
later he's like securing the location
he's getting the $5,000 or whatever the
end up price is going to be along the
way now there's some interesting things
around this so one and this is mistakes
that people like you have to deliver
what you just promised so focus on that
you just promis like hey give me a
deposit and let me take you on an
amazing golf experience so overd deliver
on what you just promised MH common
mistake that Jake was making he came
back to me I checked in on him he's like
dude these people are buying it it's
exciting I'm going to get eight people
here's the model it looks
great one guy talked to me about an app
so I'm going to start an app oh boy oh
boy and I was like squirrel yeah
squirrel that's a good movie by the way
I still I love squirrels um until the
Titans I put squirrel as my favorite
animal and so the very easy to get
distracted very easy to get distracted
and this is the the best businesses are
the ones that work and some like Jake
you just sold five people another
mistake that that very very common no
what you know I don't know about these
trips cuz I don't think I want to go on
them in a few
years I was like dude you haven't gone
on one yeah yeah guess what you know how
much work I do at abso day to day Zero
yeah I don't do any work and that's not
as like a flex like I don't do any work
no I hire the people that do the work in
they're excited and frankly they're
better than me at the work you don't
ever have to go on a trip maybe for a
podcast if you're the signature host and
it's called the Tim Fair show you
probably need to be do it unless they AI
your voice but for these golf trips
don't be so worried about making a
million when you haven't made one just
deliver the product and guess what then
do it again and then again and then
again and so that was another common
observation I was surprised and I've
seen it by others oh how's it going to
scale you haven't got a dollar don't
worry about scale yeah yeah let's just
geter don't worry about it yeah and
let's deliver the experience which now
he's getting it going in April he's
getting these people to to pay and then
it's like hey just after they pay in
April you know what you do you just do
it again and then again and then again
and then the rest of the book is now how
does he get it beyond that so it can be
Beyond his his Network and his zone of
influence also just to emphasize a few
things that you've said and also maybe
just add a couple of comments right the
whole scaling thing look I invest in
businesses this scale but I think that
what a lot of entrepreneurs tend to to
do especially if they're fantasizing
about doing something big like if it's
not huge it's a failure if it's not 10x
it's a failure if it's not this like
Paradigm shifting most businesses that
help their owners to craft unique lives
that are incredibly rewarding are
completely invisible to
you the businesses that you see on
magazine covers or in these tweet
threads and so on X threads I whatever
the cool kids are calling it these days
are outliers and trying to just model
those crazy outliers is like deciding
for New Year's you want to get into
shape so you watch a Super Bowl and
you're like okay so I'm watching how Tom
Brady
moves and if I can't be Tom
Brady then it's not exercise and you're
like well hold on a [__]
second it's not the right way to look at
it chances are so you're not Tom Brady
right so maybe before you're like it's
not worth me learning to swim unless I
can be Michael Phelps you're like well
look at his ankles you're can your
ankles do that no like I don't think so
are your hands that are you shaped like
that no you're not so just reminding
folks like you do not need to mimic the
top 1% of 1% of 1% of outliers who
probably are mutants on a bunch of
levels in order to have a business that
fulfills the dreams you have associated
with being an entrepreneur right yeah
anyway I just wanted to say that cuz
it's so common it's really common and
what you've been saying also Echo
something that Seth Goden has said on
the podcast which is I'm paraphrasing
here but effectively like do the
smallest thing possible he's like people
hide behind the big because when they
have this like I want to do an AI app
that does this and this and this which
isn't to say those things can't exist
but when they've got this huge idea I
want to help
five billion people whatever the thing
might be you can hide behind that and
never get started it's easy to hide
behind the big thing but if it's call
five of your friends you can't hide
behind that no I mean business really is
three W is what I look at it it's what's
a problem you're solving that people
care about who are those people and
where are they what's the problem that
people care about so for Jake it's a
golf trips for apps. comom it's software
deals at good prices MH for Tim Ferris
who was learning like very Tim fa show
very tactical practical things in
different areas of your life mhm where
are people listen to that that then
where are they yeah and it has been
awesome to see someone like Jake who's
had that dream be able to make that
change there are other validation
methods I'll just share because I think
people want to see other ones so one is
pre-sale so whether it's a pinball
machine which we talked about whether
it's even
apps.com I was able to get this going
within a weekend as well the same exact
method it wasn't even prale I was able
to close it all in 48 hours so just to
share another story of that I noticed
through all of my work that I was like I
like deals I like marketing and I think
the software thing is going to be big
how do I do this very quickly to find
out if this something people actually
want and that's the reason you have
weekend because you have 52 chances to
change it if it doesn't work one guess
what you have another one and another
one and at least understand a process
you're so good at this you're so good at
thinking about that so how do you I
experiment and so absum I was like I
think there's something with these three
things let me try to do in a weekend I
cold emailed imer this college kid said
hey I want to do software deals I'll pay
$7 for everyone I sell for him he's like
I get free money that's cool so a cold
email it was just and it wasun wait how
did you find the college get to cold
email because I went to mj.com oh sorry
yeah no no not some like name from aeran
okay IM no no no the website in.com so I
knew that the problem with software
deals at good prices I knew that I'm a
redditor and I was like well that's
where the customers are and then that's
who the customers are and where they are
and I was like they want imra that was
the most popular product of the time
that was all over it so basically cold
emailed Allan just Allan in.com was like
Hey I want to promote you $7 per deal
you get free money there's no cost to
you and then I was like well I can get
this posted on Reddit and I even cold
emailed the founders of Reddit and was
able to get them to give me free ads how
did you do that so curiosity why would
they give you free ads I don't really
know actually that's [__] now what
was the pitch though the pitch was
twofold one I said I knew someone they
knew okay so I worked with Chris smoke
okay when I started previous companies
he knew Chris slow uhhuh so when you're
sending an email it's really strong
subject line or any messages like
referred by blah yeah at least you're
going to get open or reply said hey I'm
working by the way don't [__] that
because you'll get fact checked I just
got someone fact checked with me like
Jord you know Jordan haringer yeah he's
a good buddy mine he fact checked
someone who messaged him like Hey no
kagan's working with me and Jordan
messages me like this guyed yeah I was
like no I'm not yeah it was a little bit
more than that basically I said hey I'd
love to just treat you to lunch and
share more what I'm working on and so I
took him to a pork store Cafe and hate
mhm and I just shared what I was working
on and said I'm doing this idea for
software deals I want to focus on Reddit
I'm a huge redditor been red since 2006
it's with iner I'd love to see if you
can give me free ads there wasn't a
bigger ass than that again we come back
full circle because you know I like
asking I practice asking everyone can
ask he's like sure crazy part of that
story fast forward about six months I
asked him again and he's like $10,000
yeah but I highly appreciate Chris and
and Reddit for giving me that free it
was they were just getting their ad
platform out mhm so it was a good chance
and that was a good chance for them like
to Showcase something or have a case
study that it worked well so I launched
it I was like if I can do 200 Sales this
is obviously a little bit bigger than
what I'm encouraging others if I can get
200 Sales within a very short time this
is it let me just break down the website
I paid $48 to a guy named Muhammad who I
can still recommend to people to help me
put a PayPal button on appa.com and I
spent $12 on appa.com I know I should
have maybe done even not the website but
that PayPal button and I post on Reddit
hey I've got a deal on imra Pro instead
of $24 it's 12 and I gave alen $7
immediately that first $12 sale was the
best dude that was so sweet and I
remember and this is the thing people
were like well how do I scale I emailed
the codes for every 200 person you know
what my backend was
Gmail I got the PayPal notification and
then I sent him an email saying thank
you so much here's your code for imra
pro what other deals do you want me to
get just what and that is what's LED now
to like 100 person team and we have all
these crazy products we've launched on
so many different things from appsumo we
have I think a 25% engineering team it
started with literally manual Gmail
codes and so the concept there is just
so [__] basic I didn't let all these
other things get in the way yeah and
also that super primitive back end that
you're talking about highly manual but
High touch with the customers yes yes
gives you a lot of really valuable input
and even though we've been talking about
word scale is kind of a four-letter word
in one of the very first episodes of
Masters of scale that Reed Hoffman did
he interviewed Brian chesk of Airbnb and
it's a it's a great episode and one of
the key tenants in the beginning for
Airbnb was do things that don't scale
and those things tended to be highly
manual helping people take photographs
of their places and what they learned
then led to a lot of what we've seen
100% I mean even think about yourself I
I hope I recall correctly I thought you
super responded to everyone super early
on I recall you in the comments on your
blog oh on the comments when I was
building that Community for sure I was
highly responsive in the blog comments
you were I remember that it stuck out to
me and that's that's exactly people are
like well how do I like have high touch
and how do I do things skill that is
literally it so for me on YouTube I
still reply to my comments not every
single one now because there's a lot but
I reply to them and guess what when you
get that message that someone actually
connected with you and this is great
especially if you're at one two three
four five customers those are the people
that stick around there so early on God
I don't I don't know if I've talked
about this at all when I had decided
that bloggers were the path at least
that was the hypothesis worth testing
for launching the 4-Hour Work week I
went
to a bunch of their blogs and I left
comments and my comments were like blog
posts unto themselves I mean they were
they took forever right but I put a ton
of energy in and I would do that in some
cases like two or three times on a given
blog where the authors were active in
the comments and they noticed that and
people bloggers in this case in many
cases directly reached out to me to
thank me for the comments right and that
laid the foundation it was like super
targeted very much sniper shot it was
not me trying a 100,000 different
things but you also in the beginning
need to throw a lot against the wall you
don't know what you're good at you don't
know what works so so you try a lot and
going back it's fun taking the trip down
memory lane for brain quicking way back
in the day the Sports Nutrition company
and I say Sports Nutrition cuz turns out
Americans did not want to be smarter at
all so selling something for improving
cognition at that point didn't work at
all but I got reports back this is when
very high touch from athletes especially
NCAA athletes who bought it for studying
they're like yeah I don't really care
about studying though but it improved my
time off the blocks for my track event
it helped me with this help me with that
and being the idiot that I was I ignored
that for ages I was like no this is
brain quaking right in my own head so I
kept panning my had against a brick wall
didn't work and eventually I was like
wait a second they're using this for
sports the only reason I spent so much
money on my supplementation as a
percentage of my incomes CU I cared
about sports performance really and then
pivoted and that's when the whole thing
took off but that's not the takeaway
that I was going to share what I was
going to share is at the very earliest
stages I had a website up which A
co-worker at work at Tran had put
together for next to nothing right cuz
we were always scheming and we were
always just like going out to lunch and
bullshitting we were friends so I paid
him but I couldn't pay him much he was
like it's fine and he put together a
website for
me I had not manufactured anything I had
done quite a bit of basic math to figure
out if the economics would work nothing
fancy though it's like how much do I
think I could manufacture this for what
are some of the basic cost of sourcing
da d da landed on a retail price and at
this point nothing has been made nothing
has been manufactured there's no product
to ship
and I just went to co-workers who were
friends and asked them if they would and
it wasn't exactly guilting but these
people at that point didn't really need
this necessarily like it could be of
benefit but I was like Hey I want to try
this out like would you be willing to
just repay for one of these so that I
can try to do a first manufacturing run
and they're like yeah sure why not you
know 50 bucks or something at the time
and that gave me just the bare minimum
of capital to start having conversations
I love that and then I had to negotiate
everything right because I would go to
these contract manufacturers and they're
like well our minimum order size is this
and in my head I'm like impossible
that's never going to work and then
they're like and our minimum term of
commitment is this I was like y also
impossible and so I had to sell the
vision and at that time I was able to
because I'd learned through cold calling
off hours get a hold of the president of
this manufacturer got him on the phone
at one point and I was just like I know
at some point somebody gave you a break
I'm not asking for anything other than
can I drive to you at any time and just
tell you about my vision for this
business
and if we are able to find a way to work
together which I would like to I promise
you that I will work with you
exclusively as a manufacturer as we grow
the business went down and I think he
was maybe just amused more than anything
else he's like okay sure like after all
was said and done and then I used them
for years right and that's how the deal
got done but it all hinged on in the
very beginning the pre-sales yeah right
and also I was buying I mean negotiating
at that time you want to talk about a
real pain in the ass magazine
advertisements feedback loop is really
slow right after you have put out the
cash for the advertising you might not
know what you're selling for months it
could take a really really long time and
so what I did when I started getting
more ambitious CU I started with small
ads of course then once I got to kind of
full page ads I would go
to say
Distributors and I would say I would
love to feature you exclusively in this
particular ad but for that to work I
would just need you to to pre-order x
amount of inventory so they buy x amount
of inventory let's say that's
$10,000 and I would also say like it's
$10,000 but the the rate card for this
full page is like 40 Grand and they'd be
like okay well seems reasonable
especially since we're going to make a
profit on the product then I would buy
the ad space as Remnant so I would
negotiate last minute I would get that
for like five grand so what has happened
if I had them pre-order let's say 10K I
paid five I'm already in the black no
matter what the outcome of the
advertisement right and this is the kind
of stuff most entrepreneurs are going to
have to do on some level something like
that right two things I want to
highlight from your story one it's
beautiful you you seem to have a knack
for finding
underserved opportunities and that's
where the opportunity is like if it's a
market there's no opportunity because
people know about it like you finding
Remnant inventory MH I think there's
something with appsumo we've had a lot
of times where like when the news feed
came out years ago on Facebook no one
was really advertising we're like oh
this is huge no one else is doing it
let's go hard on that yeah and there's
something interesting in in business and
finding what's others aren't noticing
just yet specifically for me I'm
interested in the kind of the marketing
part mhm I think the other thing that
that was interesting about what you do
is you put a little bit more extra
effort in just the sprinkle of the hot
sauce that's what you do right so one
thing and just to highlight for others
out there to copy copy it like success
leaves crumbs when you wrote a blog post
comment on other blogs you didn't just
write hey cool story thanks yeah TBO
right you wrote like actual in-depth
things that made people want to reach
out to you many many many hours on a
single comment right like 17 revisions
kind of thing and the same thing goes
for when you wanted to do the
manufacturing you didn't just say like
call the guy and be like I'll show up to
your door tell me where you're at and
I'll be there that's a little bit more
it's not a lot no it's not exclusive to
fa that's available worldwide yeah just
put in a little bit more take that
little bit of chance and what a cool
story if it doesn't work out at least
you have this crazy story that you can
talk about exactly and another little
tweak CU it's not like the story I think
that's peeling for a lot of people to
hear which is not what we're saying is I
did 100x more than the next guy that's
not what I did I did like 10% more with
some degree of Focus right and the
details matter and keep in mind I'm
copying people too right I had a three-
ring
binder which I treated as my my swipe
file whenever I bought something and at
that time magazines were a big deal
that's changed of course but like print
advertising and stuff was the game that
I was interested in anytime I was about
to buy something or I bought something
thing or I flipped through a magazine
and my attention stopped for a period of
time on an ad I would take out the ad
and i' put it in a thriving binder and I
would study the ads i' be like why why
did this affect me and then I would copy
it and to give an example just to a fine
tune right how many emails have you
received where someone's like blah blah
blah blah blah I'd love to pick your
brain and meet for coffee how about next
Tuesday at 2 p.m. right and you're like
that's pretty
presumptuous maybe that works right but
it's a little forceful yeah and in the
same way that if someone's like I'm a
hugger and they invade your space and
you back up don't cause that instinctive
defensive response and somebody reads
your emails so even in the very
beginning and I still do this because
believe it or not I get rejected it
still happens right but in the case of
say the manufacturer there was no
presumption right it was like really
appreciate you taking the time this
might not be of any interest like it was
very light I wasn't like I know what you
need this business is going to be 20x
we're going to scale and you can be our
exclusive provider no I was like this
may not be of interest but I think
there's a chance it is because I've
studied your website I've looked at this
looked at your customers I've identified
this this and
this and would love to meet everything I
just said and if that doesn't work for
you I totally understand pressure yeah
now what does that say right because
there's sort of a subtext to this what
that says is if this guy meets up with
me I'm not going to brow beat the [__]
out of him I'm not going to follow up 20
times after he said no right so he's
like the risk of me meeting with this
guy is low
because he had a light touch in the
beginning right now there's a time to be
forceful right there are times to be
more forceful but I do find that the
carrot works better than the stick or a
better way to put it is just like a
gentle touch works much more often than
a heavy touch this was also true with
the bloggers if a bunch of of bloggers
or people I thought might be bloggers
were having drinks at like an Afterparty
at South by I would wander up and I
would just say oh hey guys I know you
don't know me is it okay if I just join
you guys I'm by myself and they'd be
like okay sure and then I'd ask
questions I'd ask questions eventually
somebody be like what's your story like
who are you again and I would say oh I'm
here because the only thing I can really
control with my first book I'm really
nervous about it is looking at digital
stuff because the publisher is doing
everything else then I'd stop I wouldn't
give them a full pitch if it ended up
being the Right audience or if they had
any interest they'd be like well what's
your [__] book about right and like
well it's about funny yeah yeah well if
it's a group of like six to eight people
chances are at least one person even if
they're just being polite we'll be like
what's the story what's the book yeah
and then I would just pay attention to
who was interested right who was opting
in right and then at some point not in
front of the group by the way but like I
like buy drinks for folks like let me
buy you guys like a round of drinks I
feel like I'm crashing your party and
then if somebody really expressed
interest I would say you know zero
pressure I know you I'm sure you got a
lot going on but if you're interested I
could send you an early copy of the book
you're not going to want to read the
whole thing it'll take too long but I
could just highlight love that I could
highlight 10 pages that you might be
able to use immediately because it has
templates for this thing that you just
mentioned and they're like cool and I'll
be like yeah I'm like I'm not expecting
to promote it I'm not expecting anything
like I just want to expose people to
this stuff and you have to mean it right
that you can't then follow up 100 times
and be a prick about it like you said
you didn't expect it yeah yeah and that
worked it really worked and that
approach that light approach has worked
over and over and over again I mean it
took me two or three years to get jamy
Fox on the podcast that was a long time
right persistence and then it was like
at the time you know podcast of the year
right that's it took time that's cool
one comment and a question as well if
you start with a light ask you can do a
big ask so let me give you an example
when I knock on doors from some of the
YouTube videos where I just go to to
literally the nicest houses I see and
just knock on their door if I go to your
door and say what do you do for a living
like you're going to close it in my
face that's this rest strange instead
now what I do knocking the door hello I
love your
house they're like really yeah I just
you know we're doing a documentary on
the neighborhood and I just love your
house like can you tell me about it oh
yeah actually that that's so crazy yeah
I thought thought this I always drive by
and I was always fascinated but what'
you do for a living to be able to get
it's so great it's definitely a
different it's the same ask just done it
a little
differently that does take practice
right yeah and through time and
persistence you you do get better at it
when the last time you were rejected you
were saying you got rejected from
something I'm curious that last time and
then what do you tell yourself let's see
it depends on the type of rejection
rejection comes in all sorts of forms
right it could be silence it could
be light like polite decline or it could
be something stronger this relates back
to my pausing around a lot of next steps
for myself where I'm like if you're
rushing it's probably because you have a
scarcity perspective on
something
and if you are as I always try to and
this comes back to the question you
asked that I didn't really answer
directly if you're looking to find
something that
is rarely seen or recognized or to meet
an unmet need you have some time so I
think those opportun are everywhere and
so my feeling is if I get rejected and
I'm sure there are examples I can't
think of them off hand but there a lot
of fish in the sea right the guest
doesn't want to be on the podcast
they're too busy or whatever fine there
going to be 20 other people who will be
as good if not better possibly right if
there's an opportunity and the door
closes
because who knows right there's an
investment and blah blah blah blah blah
for XYZ different reasons
I want to make the deal happen but they
can't make it happen or I get rejected
is a strong word right but for whatever
reason I can't be part of that deal my
assumption is there're plenty of deals
like there are plenty of fat pitches out
there and that is based on experience
and I would say generally I tilt pretty
pessimistic and that I have like a dim
view of of human nature like very hobbsy
and like I'm not this bright-eyed bushy
tailed bunny that just hops around
seeing gold everywhere and the best in
people at all moments that's not me but
I would say just based on my lived
experience there opportunities [__]
everywhere there's so many million doll
and multi-million dollar opportunities
out there like they're
everywhere and for that reason when I
get turned down that's within the
entrepreneurial context I'm just like
you know that's fine maybe I got saved
for myself on this
one and that's happened tons of times
like I don't get into a deal and it's a
disas disaster unmitigated
disaster right I'm like wow okay glad
life saved me from that bro that sounds
like you're optimistic sounds like you
that's a little optimism here's what I
would say it's in this particular case
it is a very specific form of informed
optimism yeah I'm not default optimistic
I look for hedging against worst case
scenarios and so on I mean you have some
of that too right with cutting costs and
looking at these things but in this
particular case I've just seen so many
examples
of successes where you would never
predict a success right Starbucks gets
turned down by everyone they're like
another coffee company too crowded no
way right there are so many examples
when I started my podcast I was told it
was too crowded in
2014 very smart people I'm not going to
name but they said you could do it but I
feel like that ship is already sailed
2014 and I think I also
have learned to have
a less extreme response to what we might
consider rejection because number one if
you're going to be a good resource
allocator yes if you are easily offended
or get easily spun out you're going to
be exhausted a lot of the time and I
also frame so much in the form of
experiments they're not past fail this
is feedback right so I do so many things
as twoe experiments one month
experiments 3-month experiments that
applies to my podcast that applies to
everything in the business world that I
do that applies to my style of investing
like all right I'm going to experiment
with blah blah blah and then I get my
face ripped off and I'm like okay good
feedback maybe I'm not so good at X Y
and Z maybe I should stick to my bread
and butter okay well that was worth an
experiment and I C my downside so I
learned great good feedback and for all
of those reasons I would say that I'm
less reactive than I used to be but the
truth is like you told the story of Jake
there are so many opportunities out
there and I'll just say from meeting
let's just call it unmet needs or
finding Niche opportunities that other
people don't see there are a couple of
resources I'll mention and I return to
these things all the time these are
things that I reread and I'm probably
going to reread all of these again these
are just almost like montras trying to
train myself to recognize and think of
these things one would be Blue Ocean
strategy I mentioned it before excellent
book excellent excellent book how can
you be a category of one another one
I've mentioned a million times and I
mentioned a million times because I'll
read it a million times 1,000 true fans
by Kevin Kelly and then within the 22
immutable laws of marketing there's one
chapter called The Law of category and
it gives old examples so don't get the
before the internet cuz it written like
97 or something get the old version and
I think I may have even excerpted it for
either tools of Titans or tribe mentors
but it's called The Law of category and
they talk about for instance the
invention of Light
beer or being the first light beer of X
right and the first lowcost Airline I
mean these are things that came out of
nowhere and how can you create a
category of one where you're not trying
to be the best you have decided and
positioned yourself to be the only
whatever is right and I think of there
are so many examples and part of how I
assess Playing Fields also is I'm like
how hard is it right
now to create a category of one and I
look at for instance some of the early
innings in podcasting and you had people
who broke all the rules and be became
Mega successes hardcore history for
instance with Dan Carlin my favorite
podcast still to this
day his episodes I think they come out
or they historically like once every six
to N9 months maybe 6 to 12 months one
episode and they're four to five hours
long they're effectively audio books on
history no one would have predicted or
prescribed that as a successful format
nobody zero and yet it developed this
enormous cult audience and has allowed
him to do a million things now that
would be a lot harder why because it's
less human driven and more algorithm
driven right so I'm like huh okay maybe
it's time for me to choose an easier
game I don't like hard games I mean
sometimes I like to push it if I'm doing
some board game or maybe trying to ski
like right within the bounds of my
capabilities but in terms of big life
games I'm not looking to suffer I'm not
looking to you know crawl on my knees on
broken glass for 100 miles to make some
really complicated business model work
I'm like no I want until I find
something that
seems simple until I find something
where I'm like
hm maybe this doesn't need to be the
hardest thing in the
world I keep
looking all of my best investments have
been kind of
obvious and low risk all of my best
investments and when I've deviated from
that so the same criteria that I use for
entrepreneurship for Content the same
criteria I should use in investing at
least early stage stuff all the same
stuff are there other people who come to
mind who either worked off of the blog
post or that you've interacted with
personally who read early versions of
the book outside of Jake where you're
like you know this is a good example of
another person totally who's put it into
practice one thing I wanted to comment
on I got rejected yesterday was like a
mutual friend of ours he's like yeah
come on the show yesterday he's like no
don't come on the show I don't like you
I was like he didn't like that I made a
comment about him to his face yeah yeah
well I did to his face but he's been
promising for two years and so I think
younger Noah 20-year-old no would have
guilted him be like what the [__] dude
you like said you would do this thing
but what you said is actually something
I working in therapy a lot which is
instead of emotion and
react pause and respond yeah and I tell
myself that no pause which I love that
you're saying I'm like we're going the
same therapist off off mic we'll talk
about it oh my God jhead what a small
world but the pause and respond was like
okay and you're not going to guilt
anyone really into doing something that
they're excited to do and I said hey
thank you for being honest with me I
appreciated that and I'm sure that's not
what he was expecting me to say to him
but I appreciated it I was like yeah
that that must have been hard for him to
send
said it sounds like there's a little
miscommunication we're probably going to
have an experience in the future and we
might work together in the future let's
go for a walk and he's like sounds great
let's do it after the holidays and
that's definitely a matured experience
for me yeah and so the rejections keep
happening right but how we choose to
respond to them and approach them can
change with most things there are always
more opportunities it's easier for me on
the business side to see this right so
for instance you know I got out of a
very long for me relationship me a five
plus year relationship about a year ago
so in just say the dating World which is
uh has changed a lot in six years and is
very bizarre on a whole lot of levels
for the same reason that content
creators and creation have become
very different Ian a lot of the same
factors are at play gamification volume
Paradox of choice I mean all sorts of
things s of gamification of fomo right I
mean there's a lot that goes into the
similarities but on the business side
just because I've spent so much time
looking at that and I've had so much
feedback from people who have read the
first book and I've seen so many
hundreds of businesses I'm like guys
there are opportunities everywhere yeah
everywhere you also have to believe you
you're commenting on dating I was
struggling with dating in Austin and
then I struggled in La then I struggled
in in New York I was trying all these
places you also have to understand that
you have to believe it exists yeah yeah
you really do have to believe and I
found that it was easier to believe it
exists in
Barcelona by you know one optimistically
and then working on it be like holy [__]
could there really be someone out there
it's like yes there is that that is
optimism then and it's something learned
one of my favorite books this year is
learned optimism this is uh Seligman it
might be I don't know the exact but the
idea is that you can actually learn it
and practice it so through did you even
write learn Optimus
oh I do a lot of homework I do a lot of
research oh yeah I love that book and so
I was believing that my friend said to
me once this my best Bud's Jr was like
there's going to be a woman you'll meet
who's all of us combined in one H and I
was like that's [__] mhm and it took
me a few years in therapy and
relationship coach and being alone to be
like maybe there could be mhm and being
patient that that existed and then
finding it being being like wow it
really does exist and it does still take
work but it's like that was out there
yeah same with business and all these
things like believing you can have these
things so who's another example yeah
there's a guy
Pat Pat is someone I you know he is in
customer support in
Poland in Poland all right yeah he does
a customer support job probably makes
like 25,000 a year give or ticket I
don't know you know maybe that high
especially in Poland M and he's dreamed
to be an entrepreneur and he loves
YouTube loves YouTube loves it and so
he's like I'm studying YouTube
obsessively maybe I can help local
people with their YouTube channels and
so he it's not justly the pre-sale
method but close to it he was just
started contacting people that he knew
within YouTube and said let me run your
channel for you mhm and now I think he's
close to about $1,000 a month in Poland
which is basically he's a billionaire
yeah but the the idea there just taking
a step back what the elements people can
learn from where are you spending your
free time MH and he is obsessed with
YouTube he's just like I love the
channels I love the thumbnails I love
the title I love the content how do I
make that my career not being in a
customer support role and then if I
understand it maybe even go work for
free sounds like you've have experiences
around that we're like let me do a great
comment that's a free work frankly a
great comment's freee work that gets
attention so as he reached out to people
and started helping people now he's
actually got retainers on clients where
he's running their YouTube channels mhm
and so I don't know if he's quit his job
doing that I'm not sure exactly but that
was another example of him feeling good
about starting feeling good about asking
asking people and now he's got a $10,000
month business helping people with your
YouTube channels I want to Triple
underscore the free work piece because
there's a lot of righteous indignation
online about this crops up a lot with
like spec work on behalf of artists and
things like that where it's like like
I'll never work for free like people are
being exploited blah blah blah and there
are cases where that's
true everything I have done has been
built on free work if I look at all of
my biggest wins I can't think of a
single exception in the sense
that first job out of college why did I
get that because a guest speaker who was
the CEO young guy came in talked to our
class I wrote my entire term paper on
that business because I wanted to do a
free competitive analysis and show how
valuable I could be to the business
right I wrote my entire term paper on
that free work right if I look at forh
our work week had that come
about Guest lectures twice a year tons
of prep took it super seriously got
feedback everything to iterate iterate
iterate never got paid a dollar right I
spent my own money on travel you blah
blah BL blah BL all free if I look at my
investments my investments in the
startup world
right I in the beginning would do
anything I could to like co-invest with
someone to get a tiny amount of money
into the company right a few thousand
and then I would proceed to do like
$100,000 of work in terms of being like
the most valuable lowcost person on
their entire cap table I wanted them to
be like wow okay this guy owns nothing
of the company and he's materially
impacted the value of this company
including the value of my own shares as
a found found and then what happens is I
get those people who are like Tim's
[__]
awesome yeah and they are willing to do
what they're willing to say that to
other Founders and then it builds and it
builds and it
builds and people have gotten I mean
this is not going to work right now
folks so just be aware I'm in the
process of streamlining everything but
as one example like Charlie hone who
works with me for years he did
that by sending me basically the
equivalent of like the term paper that I
did for my first job right he would hear
me or rather not hear me because the
podcast didn't exist but he read my blog
posts and he got a pretty good idea of
the things that would be helpful to me
and he just did them he just went out
and put in like tens of hours maybe more
into these various projects and you be
like just wanted to send this to you I
thought it'd be
helpful and that's it right and
eventually after two or three of those
I'm like okay this is actually very
helpful love that this guy's very
proactive very detail oriented did let's
have a conversation right so there's
just to
say sometimes the best bargain that you
have is doing something for free
especially if they have time I mean
everyone has the time I mean I can give
a few other examples to kind of just
keep encouraging that I got my job at
mint because I spend a week for free
putting together a marketing plan there
you go cuz he said no to me and I said
let me just at least present you a plan
so I spent more or less at least 40
hours if not more working on a plan
brought it to me and said if you like
this plan I'll execute it you can pay me
this amount for 3 months and if I do
well and you like what the output is
then you can give me equity and $100,000
which I got three months later yeah
aming that was because I spent a whole
week for free working on it yeah I mean
same thing with a lot of the best people
I've hired within the company today Jay
Yang he's 17 years old he still has to
get a permission slip to work with us he
lives at home with his parents shout out
Jay I love this guy but he put together
I think a 30p point Google slide
presentation showing me everything
that's sucks with my social media and my
email now he's making good money working
living at his parents house so this
guy's going to be a beast he's
phenomenal right same thing with Jeremy
who's a producer of our Channel he
worked on my Instagram thing for free
two weeks Dylan who's our new producer
put together a website it's like I want
to work with no.com and it was just like
I almost always asked that question how
much hours did you put in this free work
and they're like a lot it's almost
always a lot and that's a little risk
right but at the same time one you have
something cool you can show two you
learn and three the opportunity for the
ask is pretty high and the downside is
you spend a little bit of time learning
yeah so I think that's a great call out
oh it goes on and on too now that you're
talking about it certainly the podcast
had no business model for ages I mean I
I don't think I had any sponsors until
I'd have to go back and look but episode
30 40 50 I can't remember rewinding the
clock though you mentioned something in
passing that most folks are not going to
recognize and that was opening the
kimono otk so this event did I put
together and when I did this event I was
curious I always try to go and I'm not
saying this is the right move I just
like the mathematics and the lack of
crowding in highend I always like to go
highend if I can it provides a margin of
safety that I think is there are many
reasons for it but it provides a margin
of safety that's very appealing from an
economic perspective right the better
your profit margins
the more room you have for making
mistakes so I wanted and then I work
backwards so in this case what I did was
I was like okay can't remember exactly
what I started but I was like well like
could I make whatever the number five
million bucks or whatever it was from
one event I can't remember I'm making
that number up the math isn't going to
actually compute but I worked backwards
and I was like okay if I'm going to do
that I'd gone to some high-end events
that I'd paid for and I was like well
looks like I'm going to have to charge a
lot so it's going to have to be let's
just say minimum 10 grand and then the
sooner people
purchase the less expensive it is it's
it's going to escalate so it's going to
go from 10 and like the next week it's
12.5 and then the next week it's
15,000
and it was
effectively and as one would expect with
the name sharing everything that I'd
done with my first few books at this
point I guess it was my first two books
and it was it seems very quaint at the
time because of of how constrained it
was now it would be like million and one
different tools or at least that would
be expected but content marketing at the
time which was it's more like a bathon
instead of like a quadruple you know
like uh to cathlon which it is now
there's so many different
options and I put together a blog post
which is the equivalent of like a sales
page right or an email a million
different forms this could take and then
there was an application process which
was legitimate that wasn't [__] I
wanted to make sure the composition was
impeccable I wanted the room to be not
just diverse from an experiential
perspective right I wanted a lot of
people from different Industries
different strengths different weaknesses
different networks I also wanted people
who
were [__] cool and low maintenance I
just did not want [__] and one of
the ways I vetted for that I didn't want
anyone going into debt to go to this
event I didn't want anyone jeopardizing
their finances I didn't want anyone
taking out a second mortgage I didn't
want anyone blah blah I didn't want to
be respons I for anyone else's bad
financial decisions if they were betting
the farm on this so I asked people to
provide in their Google Form application
I was like would you be willing to
provide proof that you have say at least
$100,000 in savings if you're going to
spend 15 grand on an event right and one
guy replied and he was like I don't
think you need to be my financial Nanny
but if you want to come onto the tarmac
and look at my private jet too you're
welcome to do that and I was like thank
you for disqualifying yourself you know
like don't need that guy at the event
yeah yeah no thank you and this is going
somewhere so I pre-sold the
event with a blog post and a Google form
that was it might have been woo at the
time and then then I was able to decide
by the way at that point do I really
want to do this I can still back out I
haven't taken any money right like
people have committed like they're in so
I thought about it and then I was like
all right now how do I work backwards
from this cost and ensure this was going
to be I think a 3-day event if I
remember correctly like how can I ensure
that I have the Peace of Mind of knowing
I've delivered that value in the first
few hours of the first day and I was
like okay how would I do that right this
is a question I didn't have an answer at
the time I was like well I'll do
something I've never done I'm going to
share my actual book proposals and
marketing proposals and I'll redact a
few things otherwise like as soon as we
get there that's one of the first things
I'll do I'll be like here you go keys to
the castle boom like you just made your
money back like this is worth what you
paid right the second thing I did this
is not relevant to the well it's going
to get to the point because I was
talking about buying sometimes you have
to buy your first customers right or
your first like proof of concept like if
you want Marquee clients sometimes you
have to like take a loss on that in time
or money to make it
happen I really firmly believe that for
a lot of
things just like Reddit wanted to prove
it's ad system worked they want a case
study so what do they do they give you
free advertising brilliant right that's
that's a good trade so in a way they
bought their
first case study right I'll share one
more thing just because people who run
events might find this helpful or even
just like small groups
masterminds there were bios for every
person at the event and people had a a
bound book basically with everyone's
short
bios and we took I want to say probably
two hours or roughly 100 people
and everybody in the room stood up and
they got to
do a
brag a give and then an ask oh I like
that so they get up because people
especially at higher end events are like
well you know I run a tech thing like oh
I have an app and it's like oh that
guy's like the founder of Instagram or
come on like give us a little bit more
color and that's not a real example none
of the founders of Instagram were there
but sometimes you end up in these
scenarios where people for a lot of good
reasons or not for bad reasons are being
excessively humble and then you really
just don't have an idea of what the hell
people are doing and so I was like get
up and like give a real brag hell yeah
like detailed
brag don't make it 20 minutes right give
like one to two minutes like real
brag then a give something you're really
good at or something you have access to
where you feel you're world class like
where can you help people give give a
give there's one give and then ask like
something you really need help with or
want help with could be
anything and everyone who's listening
for every person if they have a give you
need take a note if they have an ask
that you can help with write it down and
that alone I think made the event hugely
successful to this day I'd have to go
back and check but I mean literally this
was who knows I don't know 2012 or
something for at least 5 years maybe
still to this date there was a Facebook
group for those attendees that was
active every week and people still talk
about it now coming back to the original
point I'm talking so much in this but
it's more like a conversation than a
podcast at this point that's isn't that
a podcast podcast what's a
podcast I spent so much [__] money on
that event to overd deliver right like
rented out a castle had like flamco
dancers fcking classical musicians and
plus by the way if you do an event in
Napa you're dealing with basically the
cartel not like Mafia cartel but
coincidentally everybody's going to
charge $8 for a cup of coffee right
you're not going to be able to negotiate
anything my point so this event ended up
being so incredibly expensive basically
made nothing
but was a huge home run for people I
felt really good about it I learned a
ton was an incredible investment of time
right so one could argue that was that
was a waste of time but I developed
relationships with 100 people who I
handpicked right I had speakers at the
event and a lot of questions that
informed the whole thing and if I ever
wanted to do another event I would guess
I would have at least 90% of those
people who would immediately book a
second like otk 2 done no problem so if
I ever fell in hard times quit the
podcast business I'm like you know what
I'm just going to do like one event a
year I know that that will work because
I can pull different levers I've talked
to people who went to that event and
they're like that was the best event
ever went to and I was a little jealous
I didn't go I didn't I don't know if I
saw the blog post but a few comments
it's like it's really interesting you're
like you didn't build a website you you
sent out an email which you everyone can
do that right now if you want to start a
business you can pre-sell have a form I
like that idea of like how do you survey
people yeah and then you could filter
who do you want to sell to and see if
they're raising their hand to be
customers and then you could sell them
something I I love that something you
said literally years ago it was in
Denver remember the what was the
conference we were both at somewhere in
Denver 303 conference I can't remember
it was the those two brothers born SE
Bros oh okay yeah yeah and you said on
conference I never forgot about this cuz
you said I either do the most expensive
or free
Y and I loved that because I'm always
about the best price and the low end
that's my thing I love it I'm like give
me the best deal and so AB suumo is
about great deals and then you as well
like you want to do POS C sponsorship
it's going to be 50 60 whatever 40K it's
going to be the most expensive and
you're going to get very high quality
delivery and then how do you work
backwards from that you don't have to
figure it out in advance right that's
interesting I decided like okay I want
this to part of the marketing
positioning is how premium this podcast
is right it is incred inedibly
expensive I mean we're going to get into
the weeds here
but talking about like the 10% what's
the extra 10% right that you can do like
in the case of me pitching the
manufacturer or whatever so one thing
that I've done with a lot of my sponsors
not everybody because not everybody
needs this but what are the levers in a
podcast all right well let's just say
the basic economic model for most
podcasts not all is sponsorship people
are buying ads why are they buying ads
because they want to sell products what
are some of the metrics that matter to
someone trying to sell products let's
assume for Simplicity sake that we're
talking about direct response let's say
we're talking about appsumo you're going
to be tracking the numbers that you just
mentioned right traffic conversion
average order size now let's say appsumo
came to Tim Ferris show and decided we
want a
sponsor hypothetically let's say number
one I have to try the product so I I
test every single product
within reason there's some like
Enterprise stuff in which case I'll do a
bunch of polling and determine how my
audience feels like 1 to 10 no 7 allow
how strongly would you recommend this to
a friend do it off hours so the people
who work at the company don't see it and
can't spam It Anyway there ways to do it
if you don't test but I generally test
stuff let's say I test ABS I'm like
great [__]
product what is the additional 10% the
additional 10% I will look at the
website and I'll will say how well does
this convert because what is a nightmare
scenario for me because I'm one could
say efficient one could say lazy they're
similar that's interesting if someone
has a great product and I put time into
a great read and I put it in front of my
audience and then their website doesn't
convert and they blame it on me that's
way too much brain damage way too much
wasted effort now I have churn right
they're like well your podcast didn't
work and they leave and then I have to
find another podcast sponsor okay so I
might send my team to that sponsor P to
loom and say we'd love to have you as a
sponsor but we'd like you to make these
following changes to the website at
least to a unique landing page to
improve conversion we'd like you to
improve in the following seven ways in
the same way that that 17-year-old sent
you a video which was like here's how
these things suck I wouldn't word it
that way but I'd say we want you to
convert as strongly as possible we know
our audience really well this is how
they're going to read your website
here's what the flow looks like these
are two plac where they're probably
going to abandon the cart fix fix fix
doesn't take that long cuz we've done it
a million times and then guess what then
I have a sponsor who lasts like a year
two years three years and they spend
millions of dollars instead of spending
a lot on the upfront and then churning
right love that it sounds like a lot but
it's actually not that much effort if
you have the right team so let's hop
back into the weeds of
Entrepreneurship that sounds bad onto
the front lines validation what are some
other means of validating your idea to
try to ensure that you're not deluding
yourself any more than is helpful yeah I
mean I've done it the other way where
I've spent six months I built a site bet
arcade.com spent six months $100,000 on
Engineers o and then I spent $10,000
flying to Vegas talking to a lawyer as a
sports betting site first off I don't
gamble yeah not a great business for me
to even start launched it no one came
yeah I could have easily found that out
on a weekend and this is the thing I'm
like trying to tell people I've done it
the other way maybe you need to go
through the other way to find that that
truth for yourself but there's another
door MH so two other ways that you can
validate business ideas that I really
like I would say the one that you really
made famous ads landing page yep one I
don't like spending money if I don't
have to ads cost money and then you have
to figure out the ad and landing page
but it is a way like kettle and fire you
know Justin's company that's how it got
started he did bone broth ads he found
out it was super cheap term had a
landing page people could buy and he's
like this is working and now it's a $100
million business yeah so he followed
your method y the other method I would
say is marketplaces so where are are
people already spending money that
they're raising their hand so Etsy
Craigslist Facebook Amazon and how can
you put even a fake or real product
ideally and see if anyone's going to buy
it so let's say you want to do like
a digital equipment like microphones
cameras lighting business as a rental
you can go put that online right now on
craigus in your local area or whatever
site is local and see does anyone
actually message you about it yeah and
if they do cool go get the product or
figure out now you have a business or if
they don't okay try something else out
so those are the other two ways outside
of I would say the pre-selling
validation method to seeing if you have
actual customers who want what you're
doing yeah totally and the constraint of
spending as little as possible will
generally this is very broad strokes but
in my experience and certainly in the
experience of a lot of people who are
building businesses not mimicking the 1%
of the 1% of the 1% right like the I
Can't Get Fit until I'm Tom Tom Brady
which is generally not a great approach
but the people are building real
businesses businesses that produce a lot
lot of cash very often test incredibly
inexpensively right if you look at the
origins of CrossFit that's the case
right I remember the very early super
early days of CrossFit this was not a
let's put $30 million in and see what
happens right it was Prototype iterate
prototype iterate small group second
location considering business models Etc
I mean this is true in so many so many
so many different places any other means
of validation that you want to mention
or an example of someone who used any
one of those that comes to mind you
already mentioned Kettle and fire but
any yeah I mean another one you could
think of what kind of silly is Facebook
okay I mean Zuck copied he didn't even
invent it this this website and that
wasn't his first business he actually
created a face thing that got banned by
Harvard s to start again then he created
wirehog no one knows these ones but I
don't know anything about that yeah
wirehog was a Napster competitor okay
that didn't really do much but again one
thing in the beginning of the book is
how do you get going and he at least got
going and and his third idea which was
Facebook orth facebook.com believe he
built it in a weekend if not 3 days it
might give or take and just by him he
sent an email built it really quick sent
an email and then it went viral
instantly wasn't even his idea he copied
the Winkle vosses yeah and there's just
a lot of these ideas you're like you
start realizing it most of the biggest
businesses didn't start big like Okay
Google two dudes at Stanford for a
research project huh that's interesting
Zuck in a college dorm Bill Gates in
Albuquerque shout out Albuquerque you
know working for someone else creating
software and it was by doing these
things where you had validation very
quickly and had success that people
wanted it led them then to continue it
for you know extended periods of time
and that's possible I think here's what
happens though Tim Tim if I make this is
the [__] problem man everyone's like
my business is different it's the unique
one I'm like you're the unique one
really it's you okay do it just go try
it your way yeah and then let's try
maybe an alternative way after six
months with no
results so Cory do the easy thing first
like if you really wanted do the hard
way okay fine like what you really want
to do is
like build the flashy website and like
do the thing and like hire a bunch of
influencers and have girls in bikinis
prancing around with your energy drink
whatever okay fine maybe you could start
though with a blog post maybe you could
start with an email maybe you could
start with something that's very cheap
very fast yep fast fast fast constraints
are you hiding behind something big are
you talking about the sexy photo Sho and
the Super Bowl ad that you're never
[__] going to do not because you
couldn't do it but because you're hiding
behind the big thing and you're not
trying the small thing like what is the
easy thing that you can do first do that
right and this comes up all the time in
my business when I'm talking with
employees for instance who have already
embraced this by this point but I'm like
we can do the hard thing we can do the
expensive thing I'm not averse to it but
what is something fast or something
cheap that we can do first because if it
works
then that is a game Cher and then we
have these backup plans I'll give you
another
example how can you keep your life
incredibly simple well in the case of
podcasting in the
beginning I realized if I end up with
tons of accounts payable accounts
receivable invoices net payment terms
Etc that will insert a lot of complexity
into my life so from the very beginning
I did something that a lot of folks said
would never work which was you prepay
for all your ads there's no you book and
then you run it and then you pay us 30
days later and then that drags out
because it's a holidays or maybe you
don't reply to email and then we're
chasing you there's none of that you pay
up front that's it love that and that is
an example of let's try the easy thing
first or the simple thing the beneficial
thing right if people say no we can
always go to Net 30 because everyone
does that but let's try the unorthodox
thing first in the sake of
Simplicity and every once in a while it
works right and that ended up being a
key determinant I think
of my ability to build and scale and
most importantly sustain this for 10
years my dad would always joke it's
better to be chased for the money than
you chase them oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's better to be on that end of
things I'd say that's definitely how the
appsumo model has worked out
the the idea with auma just maybe a few
more examples to get people like oh [__]
I can really get going you know we say
now not how and that's definitely from
the book and so examples of this is the
team's like we definitely need the
engineers to build this first definitely
I'm like really all right let me give
you two examples so as part of our VIP
memberships we wanted to give out
credits so kind of like your event how
do we make spending $100 for a
membership at no-brainer well we give
you a $100 yeah so they're like well we
need to build it right we did the model
fine but let's go build it I'm like no
no no what's the fastest way you can
find out today let's email people who
are not customers or people who canceled
give them free credit tell them to buy
our membership and if they buy their
membership they get free
credit they did it it was a 17%
conversion rate now we're building that
kind of stuff into the business great
you did it and if it didn't work you can
ask those people why not M or you can
try something else instead of us
spending a week two weeks four weeks a
month two months now product management
it designing it these other things yeah
there's another example recently where
we want to offer a new feature for this
VIP membership the same thing they're
like well we need the engineers to build
SSO single sign on so that you can make
it easy to log in again have you ask the
customer just go ask the customers to
pay us for it if they want this feature
see if they'll prepay for it and if they
do great we'll build it if not we're not
going to build it and that is something
that you can keep doing whether you're
an 80 million or 100 million or a $1
business yeah
totally a lot of the time in terms of
now not how right we think often times
and there's a place for this but you
know Ready Aim Fire sometimes it's ready
fire aim or just fire right fire fire
fire fire fire fire fire fire all right
so we're going to take a hard left turn
here because you mentioned before we
started you mentioned Hanukkah gifts and
the question I often ask is best
purchases for under $50 under $100 right
what has made some impact because the
goal is to give people listening some
things that might be helpful or
interesting that aren't going to break
the bank right 100% what you got all
right so Hanukkah or you know the Jewish
Santa AKA Noah Kagan here brought you
Hanukkah holiday yala K Quanza all the
gifts depending on whatever people want
and so these are my favorite things I
think almost every single thing here is
under 40 bucks great that I've brought
for you and I don't and by the way you
totally give it back you know people
gift you and you're like [__] I really
don't want this feel free to be like y
or nay on it too okay all right first
off this didn't expect a bag of goodies
okay all right this is my I wasn't able
to get the Amazon Basics one cuz it's
sold out but this is a I think $14 $15
tiny travel backpack and so I always
leave one in my main suitcase yeah and
every time you travel you're like ah
[__] I want to do a day trip but I don't
want to carry my computer backpack and I
don't have anything else yeah so I
always leave a similar one to this in my
bag you this onon literally I was going
to be buying one of these in the next
few weeks so thank you that's a yay okay
this is a yay this is 100% a yay because
as you said you think you already have a
backpack but that thing is full of your
laptop and all your [__] and it's heavy
and it's you sometimes just want a day
pack that's what this is so this is EA
all right awesome you like board games
this has been the go-to board game shot
and Totten shot and to it's $1.99 it
must be oh look at this okay so never
I've never played it it's a more basic C
it's kind of like poker but with cart so
you get all these different players and
then you to Kilt exclamation Boy that's
the tagline I like it you had the taco
cat game I bought that cuz you're five
bullet Friday love yeah it's a fun game
similar game basically layout cards it's
a two-player game and then you just play
against for different each of the cards
there's about 10 and you play three
cards I play three cards and whoever has
the better three set gets that card and
whoever gets the most cards wins the
game that was a little fast but super
awesome game shout out southw he's the
one who uh brought that board game to me
yeah thank you and also I want to
highlight something here just because I
recognized something so shot and tton I
was like this must be German so of
course it is and the Germans are very
good at at designing board games and
more precisely Riner kitzia I believe
that's how You' say his name who
designed this yeah is one of the most
prolific game designers in history he's
designed hundreds of games and he's won
all of the awards and he has this
incredible set of processes and sort of
creative methods by which he's one of
the most successful game designers of
all time so that's also cool to see his
I didn't realize that yeah seant ton one
of my favorites thank you you have
element you've tried element right oh
yeah sponsor of the podcast too I was
going to bring you already have a bunch
of it don't you uh well let me what you
got no just like I got I brought you the
Citrus salt oh I got a ton yeah thank
you that is one of my favorite flavors
but yes I took it I take it every day
they sponsor me too did you invest in
them no no no I didn't I didn't all
right I couldn't get it in time so I
just printed it out dude this is shout
out tin.com one of my best friends in
the world what is it he was the one that
taught me about this it's basically
travel Clippers I'm a huge nail clipper
oh I'm very particular about my nail
clipping like all these [__] Walgreen
CVS they're just [__] and I finally I
got this cuz on his recommendation and
it's a game changer there I wasn't going
to give you mine but that's kind of
that's too weird yeah be a little gritty
a little weird so this is going to your
to your address okaying a $39.99 it's
literally this big okay so it's like so
it's like the size of your pinky finger
size of your pinky finger it's very low
profile super low profile and for people
who want to find this how would they
search it this is a zwilling zwilling
ohing like the kitchen knife company
exactly and this is fire so super tiny
but it opens up up and the sharpness of
it which I'm very particular about you
can ask my girlfriend she's like you
always cut your nails I'm like yeah I
hate long nails I love this guy so big
shout out for this cuz I've always been
looking for like the perfect one wow $
39.99 all right we'll put this in the
show notes for everybody along with the
other Hanukkah gifts Hanukkah
holiday I think you may have read it but
I brought you my favorite kind of memoir
book of all time million miles in a
thousand years I
am actually going to admit I have never
even heard of this book so tell more
this guy okay quote from Ann Lamont who
owns the author of one of my favorite
books also what book is that bird by
bird on creative process oh by the way
you're Julia Cameron artist way oh
thanks that book is so it's a good one
it's a good one yeah so an lamot has an
amazing quote on the cover of this so
Donald Miller how I learn to live a
better story is the subtitle that's cool
already a million miles in a thousand
years this is the book I gift the most
okay and it inspired me to bike Across
America mhm but the the bigger concept
for everyone out there is that we all
want to live a life without regret we
all want to live not even with I don't
worry about that we all want to live an
interesting life and so how do you do it
and so Donald doesn't and he's a
Christian Author talks about Jes I'm
Jewish like and I love it still it's
still my favorite book and he's
definitely I love him and what he
teaches you though is it's not
necessarily the tactic but how do you
approach life to be more interesting so
how are you around more interesting
people how do you do more interesting
things like he didn't like his life
mhm and he was like I'm just going to B
cross America and so he joined a group
and then biked AC cross America and he
by doing interesting things he led an
interesting life and I think it's it's
similar to the 4our work week a million
dollar weekend where you read it and
you're like I'm going to go do something
MH and I think this really is that about
how to have a a fulfilling an
interesting life amazing I'll give a
little teaser then also so here's the
top of the back of the book after
writing a successful Memoir Donald
Miller's life stalled during what should
have been the height of his success he
found himself unwilling to get out of
bed avoiding responsibility even
questioning the meaning of life but when
two movie Producers proposed turning his
Memoir into a movie he found himself
launched into a new story filled with
risk possibility Beauty and
meaning and then I'll just give the
first portion of the first sentence that
then leads after that which is a million
miles and a thousand years Chronicles
Miller's rare opportunity to edit his
life into a great
story goes from sleeping all day to
riding his bike Across America amazing
all right yeah man and we all can live
an interesting life it's not so far so
good man oh yeah man and I brought you
back in old one this is an old one our
team was was looking up
things this is what you put on your blog
in 200 I think 11 oh my God one of your
favorite toys I know what this is this
is hilarious okay this is like a monkey
slingshot and it screams when you shoot
it across the room wow I haven't seen
one of these in a long time this was a
early recommendation that you put on
your site this must have been from the
pleine eron on my blog way back in the
day yeah we did a little research and so
know you like that I got one for my
house it is [__] annoying it'll drive
you nuts my it'll drive you completely
insane it's a fun toy I got it for other
people for the holidays and I think it's
like I'm like giving it to them and
getting the hell out of their house cuz
the screaming is loud flying monkey yeah
no it is it is not it is not low volume
thank you yeah man happy holidays I
appreciate it and I can put all of that
into the backpack that you gave me also
exactly this last one I love my pilot G
2.38 I need get sponsored by these guys
I know you have pens and I've seen you
have pens all around but this is just
like everywhere I travel I always have
have with me here I bring them to Spain
have it all around the house boxes of
them yeah this is one of my favorite
pens and I needed one and I use blue I
almost always use blue instead of black
because I copyedit a lot and if you're
printing stuff out it's in black blue
just makes it easier so nailed it damn
thank you hell yeah man pilot G
2.38 all right where to go from here I
mean what have we missed we've talked
we've gone from the philosophical to
hire mymom.com to nail clippers to B
bicycling across the United States
anything else that you'd like to mention
let well actually let me ask you a
question that relates to things I'm
considering just to ask you for help so
YouTube how do you think about
YouTube and do you think I should do
more video because I have conflicting
feelings about it as you know and then
there's always that voice not always but
there's that voice maybe 10% of the time
which is just like are you just being
weak are you just afraid to compete
right which comes up with various things
like maybe you're intimidated by the
production quality the ability that you
see here so you're just not willing to
play the game because you don't like
losing that's less of the time that's
like 10 20% of the time thoughts on
YouTube and specifically thoughts on if
you think I could do YouTube in a way
that would be fun and energtic izing in
and of itself so in other words
something that I would find
intrinsically rewarding even if it
doesn't pop yeah I'm curious the voice
in your head with this YouTube with like
what's 10 or 20% well it's not all the
time I was just talking to a friend of
mine about this yesterday
I like competing I've always been a good
competitor right it drives me and I
enjoy the stakes of competition in
sports I enjoy the stakes of competition
and million different ways like it
drives me to be better and it genuinely
is something that I derive pleasure from
like I get a lot out of competition so
there are things that for instance at
some point I would love to compete in
archery and think there are some
interesting opportunities there I'm a
happier person when I compete in some
capacities oh yeah so being very
competitive seeing the market get really
saturated with podcasts and seeing some
very good people come in and how it's
skewed pretty heavily into entertainment
right so it is it is gone
from I think what I find place to my
strengths which is mostly kind of
education practical tactical Etc skewed
pretty heavily towards Entertainer bust
right you can have some of the how-to
and prescription but you must be
entertaining to cut through the noise
yeah and I can be funny occasionally but
it's not my it's not something I do
professionally there are people who are
far better yeah Pros right Pros yeah
like Rogan I mean he's a pro right like
this is a superpower that he's honed and
there are many others a lot of
entertainers comedians actors actresses
who are really good behind the mic and
front of the
camera so I think there is certainly
part of me because I like to compete and
I generally hate losing and you have to
be careful with how you define losing
because you could find yourself caught
in sort of a venus fly trap of fomo and
all sorts of issues which I don't
contend with that much to be honest but
that voice is one of are you sure that
you are opting out of this for good
reasons or is it because you just don't
want to
compete what would make great coaches
don't don't give Answers by the way they
just ask questions all right so oh you
reminded me you're not getting out of
here we'll talk a little about coaches
we'll do the 48 hour challenge maybe we
can put frontload a little bit of that
here's the question around this YouTube
thing what would make the choice obvious
if I'm being honest I think the choice
is obvious which is I don't do it I mean
I think that like I mean I think I think
it's pretty straightforward partially
because I see no way to make YouTube Pop
without compromising my
privacy more than I already have from a
facial recognition
perspective and that is already a
challenging aspect of my life from a
privacy security perspective like a lot
of weird stuff happens and if anybody's
curious just read a blog post I wrote
which is titled I think it's 11 reasons
not to become famous and that'll outline
a lot of the issues by the way that
people who were just starting out maybe
a year prior to that coming out have by
and large I'm in a number of private
WhatsApp groups with various folks and a
lot of very very successful creators and
they're like oh yeah check check check
like right down the list I've had to
deal with all of those things so it's
not unique to me and they're much bigger
celebrities of course I'm not Taylor
Swift or
something but I actually really like my
privacy so I think that if I had to make
a snap judgment decision right now it's
like yeah I'm not going to use that as a
primary tool it's appealing though
because I recognize how effective it can
be if you do a great job but there's
also part of me looks at it I'm like
well much like choosing a business much
like choosing anything a sport to play
if you don't have an advantage
and that Advantage often is that you
really enjoy doing it on some level
you're not going to have at the very
least the staying power to persist over
time you're not going to have the
endurance right so it's like if you love
golf maybe you should consider doing
something with golf instead of being
like well I think Midwestern moms even
though I'm from New York City and I'm a
male I think Midwestern moms really need
this when their kid is four years old
like maybe that shouldn't be your
business because if there's a Midwestern
mom who has a 4-year-old who's got
nothing but passion in her veins for
that she's going to beat you right like
she's going to own you especially over
time so that's another way that I think
about it but I also assume that there
may be things hiding in plain sight that
I'm missing I got suggestions for you
that I think will be low effort High
results but before we get into that
what's your goal what's my goal yeah
what would you say your goal is around I
I mean I think the goals around it would
be to experiment with one of the
few means that I see of expanding the
podcast like I
do a lot with this podcast in terms of
pulling interesting levers in the world
right as a means
of attempting to the best of my ability
to really impact individual lives but
also on a macro level to really change
conversations around say psychedelics
and psychedelic assisted Therapies also
discussing risks but there are many
different things I would like to
introduce people to and the larger my
audience
is I should say qualified audience right
I'm not convinced that YouTube
necessarily will contribute to the
profile of
my say audience as it stands
today TBD I think it probably could if I
could expand the reach of the podcast
and if I'm talking to most podcasters
who have been around for a while given a
lot of the platform changes and given
the blackbox nature of a lot of the
analytics once you hit a critical mass
it becomes very challenging to grow your
podcast there is nobody after two drinks
of there being honest with me who says
anything otherwise like there is a grace
period in the beginning when you have
that kind of meteoric up and to the
right right but it's like this is going
to be an exaggeration it's like once you
become like when you're becoming Google
sure you can have that like double
triple 10x every year growth but when
you get to a certain point it becomes
more challenging on a percentage basis
to influence the size of the the ship
you know the Mother Ship so the goal and
I'm not convinced that YouTube is the
only way but is to extend the reach of
the podcast at this point there are
other metrics I could pull in but let's
use that for Simplicity sake I think
that's a great question is how do you
stay hungry when you're full or do you
need to stay hungry I think that's
another way that's a great point it's
like what happens when you finally have
the money when you have the audience and
so how do we rethink what that vision
and that purpose is right I noticed that
was a shift for myself we like oh if I
finally get money it's like dude you got
it you don't need to be angry about Mark
and Facebook anymore no no for for
myself right it was it was therapy and a
lot of work to be able to get to the
point where it's like how do I want to
spend that day yeah and it's like my day
can talk about money and startups and
business with people like yourself and
learn how you think about things run app
Su we promote tools like
wow I can do this every day for until I
never die yeah and so I think being you
know clear on the goal of where it goes
like for me with my content I just want
to keep doing it for 10 years yeah so
I'm on a 10 year 10 year plan yeah
that's a balance of I like doing just
business stuff I don't do bouncy balls I
don't blow up Ferraris I'm not in prison
there's no squid games unless it's a
business related one yeah it's like how
do I do that with what I want and what
the audience is going to be benefited by
for a long period of time and that
that's specifically with content my
interest okay so what might be sort of
low effort High reward experiments a few
things number one who says you have to
be on the camera now when you're doing
these videos I was thinking that I just
don't know what the alternative looks
like well it's just you're asking the
question but then your guest is the one
getting featured yeah so there's
actually a reduction of the amount of
exposure as well as on your YouTube
thumbnails that doesn't even show you it
just shows the guest yeah and so there
could be wide shots but it really could
be a show where it's more featuring the
person you're talking to yeah totally so
that is one massive thing that in your
channel right you can actually have
great content but it's not maybe you on
camera second thing how much like I can
tell but how much are you putting into
like producing your YouTube
videos uh I I honestly don't even know
at this point I mean I I want to be like
the tools we use shape us right so
I depends on what we mean by production
I'm okay with high production value what
I have seen on YouTube in the last year
and a half two years
especially is a lot of fishing for
clippable moments with like the most
salacious click
baity stuff used as headlines and text
overlays and I do not want to shape
myself
into looking at my content through the
lens of like when can I clip something
into the Jerry Springer fight scene yeah
yeah my baby mama you know like I don't
want to suddenly go fishing for that cuz
that will start to affect the macro
level right like I know people who plan
their podcasts now around like the clips
the clips and so the the drive becomes
the clips now I'm
also I think longer form YouTube this is
something where I'm unqualified to say
but I have had
Clips on different platforms that have
had like a 100 million views I mean I've
had a couple go nuts which is a credit
to my team however with those clips
which have clear attribution to this
podcast I have seen
effectively 0% conversion to increased
downloads so the value capture from the
platforms it's a very subtle thing but
the amount of value that platforms are
capturing they capture is all the they
get all the value all theide that's a
whole discussion Creator value
capture is something I have paid
attention to and continue to pay
attention to but why do you ask about
the like how much I'm putting into well
I'm coming back on like small effort
High results so what you keep saying or
the underlying subtext is that you want
to grow the podcast yeah it seems like
growing the podcast is it's not clear
that YouTube actually makes a difference
I would wonder what have you done in the
past that grew the podcast yeah I mean I
would also say if I had to pick and
choose at this point frankly just in
terms of like okay winter is coming not
to be all dramatic about it but if I'm
looking at and and keeping in mind mind
too it's it's not like I have any
Insider information but I do know a lot
of people in Tech who work on a lot of
things and if I'm thinking about
defensibility long-term viability
reaching my 1,000 true fans and
hopefully 1,000 or one million true fans
two million true fans you know I mean
we're already in the millions with with
the newsletter and so on but I would
choose the newsletter over the
podcast at this point right I mean
coming back to I think how we like to
approach how can you experiment and so
let me give you specifics how can you
experiment with YouTube to drive a
newsletter yeah I don't know I think
that's where I would look at it because
you're thinking YouTube to podcast but
maybe YouTube to newsletter so
specifically thumbnails not really that
tight your title is not really that
tight because you probably don't have
Pros like we have a professional person
that just does title in thumbnails yeah
and we have a thumbnail specific just
designer mhm for the team it is
interesting do you want to compete in it
maybe not but I think you're already
doing it right you have cameras here
yeah I do I mean and so passing that to
a team that yeah chops it up so for me I
show up to the video they have the
pre-production done I've already chosen
the topics we've agreed on that
pre-production done I show up do my part
and then it just it happens yeah but
they're testing thumbnails they're
testing titles there's a shorts team
that does all the short work yeah and
what I my recommendation is is that I
think you can invest a little more in
that and then just put that into your
newsletter like all of YouTube is is a
leg gen that leg gen always sounds so
creepy but like as a generation of
audience that you can then have as a
frequent audience in your newsletter I
wonder I wonder I mean it's worth
testing I know we've tested different
subscription options I don't want to
take us too too far a field so again I
think you could do have short shorts
team probably actually a dedicated
agency I wouldn't even put bring it in
house I can recommend someone I would
also consider just having someone that
does your titles and thumbnails on a
consistent basis so that as you're doing
great content does someone want to watch
this six hour
interview yeah a lot do but give them
some shorts because they see great
shorts they're like oh [__] where's more
of that and they go to the video they
see the video then in the videos it's
like let me go to the newsletter and
everything is around the newsletter now
on the podcast I always again in
business everything is about what's the
thing that what's the goal and what's
the thing that actually makes impact on
the goal MH so on podcast I do think you
get potentially going on other shows
could be yeah it always helps yeah if
you want to do it I think that's an
important part that you said I don't
want to I want to do it or I don't like
have to be mindful what we want to
actually commit to because that's how
people burn out doing the thing they
don't want to do to the goal they may or
may not actually want yeah for sure also
I'm aware that the drive to compete can
lead me to do things that are not
actually in my best interest 100% right
just because you can win at a game or
think you could win doesn't mean you
should participate in that game that is
how you create a life you don't want to
live yeah I don't feel I don't feel
rushed
um TBD to be continued we may pick up
offline chatting about that but let's
let's make sure we talk about a few
things two things so the first is and we
don't have to spend a ton of time on
this but spend a little bit of time
lessons from from spending more than a
million dollars on coaching so I've got
all sorts of bullets here CEO coach Biz
coach boxing coach therapist health
coach marketing coach dating coach three
different ones Hebrew and now Spanish
coach and the question I want to ask is
related to all these inputs because we
also talked about the top three bottom
three the weekly the monthly the q1 the
this the that and what we were talking
about is we took a break a a little bit
ago just for a bathroom break you I've
seen many examples of people including
myself get inundated with inputs this
happens also when people read too many
books or they have too many advisers for
the startup and now they have 20 people
they respect or 10 people they respect
even four people they respect giving
them conflicting
recommendations or it's just too many
recommendations 100% right if you have a
100 Years resolutions you have no New
Year's resolutions so the first thing
I'm curious about is like how for
yourself do you choose what to act on
outside of the business kpis and stuff
let's just say let's break these down
let's take let's take my marketing coach
so I work with Moody Glasco and cold
messaged him on LinkedIn now when you
think about coaching I think instead of
having mentors let's have very specific
coaches in very specific areas that I'm
weak in or the people around me we have
a lot of coaches for the team almost
every single leader in executive team of
abum has a coach MH and with Moody it
was going to him and saying I'm not as
strong on some of the data stuff I'm not
as strong on some of the marketing
research stuff and branding stuff those
are my specific areas of need and when
we meet let's really focus on that now
this is really the interesting caveat
with coaches you're getting a coach
because it's the things you don't want
to do or the things you're not aware of
and so you have to be mindful of
resistance MH the resistance is
almost always the direction I've noticed
that ends up happening and I just maybe
don't always do it right away mhm so
moody for
instance is really wanted to do a lot of
surveys like Moody I don't do surveys
man just let me go like put up some ads
let me go do let's do more affiliate
marketing let's do more video Ambassador
sponsorship he's like who are you doing
that for I don't know dude I don't want
to do research let's go do stuff I'm a
doer yeah and so his balance of these
things is saying let's go do some
research so we know who we're doing it
for and be very specific who the
customer is now you asked the question
of inputs I think the inputs need to tie
to your main priorities
that's it so what is the priorities I'm
saying so within our marketing team
right now it's getting a vpm marketing
it's content and it's brand awareness
also video ambassadors getting more of
those and So within inputs I'm just like
specifically going over those specific
problems and saying walk me through how
you're normally thinking about solving
this and then he normally is coaching me
and we're having a discussion around it
what I have found with most of the
inputs is that I end up doing them
almost always six months
later because I resist them and I'm
going to do what I want to do anyways
just like most people here maybe want to
start business their way then six months
later they they think about the coach
the other thing with him specifically on
taking inputs I record all my coaching
calls every single one MH every single
one and then I go and listen to them
again not all the time but selectively
depending on if I'm trying to learn
something noticing how I'm resisting
noticing where I'm paying attention and
that helps me be able to be a better
student with my coach MH so coming back
full circle with coaching in general how
to choose the input it comes back to my
priorities and the specific problem I'm
goinging to them with and a lot of times
it's then sitting with the answer that
they bring back to me as one example
from the bullet list so CEO coach would
that be Dan from reboot that's Dan putt
as well as Aman alabdullah so Dan is
more feelings and then Aman's more
strategic so how would you describe some
of the benefits from working with those
guys just in terms of looking in the
rearview mirror so I can think of a
number of coaches I've worked with it's
like oh I picked up up the whole body
yes from that person that ended up being
really important and then you give
another person oh okay I took this thing
away from them and it was very valuable
what are some of the things you would
point to let's take Aman Alaba for
instance I am going over 2024 strategy
and so I talk to customers I talk to
Partners I talk to team we look at
historically what we've done and we put
together a one pager plan and one of the
ideas is we have original products we
basically create affordable low-entry
versions of popular products so
MailChimp we have an alternative Ken Le
we have an alternative
and I went to him and I said hey we're
going to let me walk over the one thing
I'm uncertain of is 2024 and around what
we should do with new
products and brought it to him walked
over it you know I'm so convinced that
we need to build a bunch of new things
I'm like dude this new stuff is going to
be so sick we're going to build a loom
alternative we're going to build this
other product alternative maybe a doc
sign alternative and because I have air
I have him and I like coaches who've
done the things I want to do he's ran
the business he's former CEO so like no
what's working in your products that you
guys have built I'm like oh we have this
one product it's crushing it okay so you
have a product crushing it and you want
to do a new one how come y I'm like oh
that's
good we're not doing a new product yet
yeah we're doubling the team so that we
can have a core team keep investing in
what's working instead of moving off to
the new thing and so that was a really
powerful example of him just asking
questions based on strategy and and
understanding our business based on
something I was like oh here's what I'm
thinking and here's my problem what
should we do next year mhm and then he's
redirected me I think in a very
effective way so that was one example
with him we talked about Dan putt just
having an outlet frankly you've gone to
therapy I still go to therapy yeah so
with Dan we were talking on Monday about
he was just asking me how you feeling
about the future I was like I feel
really unclear this what we're talking
about I don't feel like the whole team
and myself really are crystal clear and
fought what we want to do in q1 huh what
do you want to do about that I'm going
to set up a meeting right now for
tomorrow so that we can all be on the
same page for q1 and their scorecard for
the company and then each of the
separate teams and that was from a
5-minute question with Dan yeah and then
so it's really just thinking about all
these different areas like Moody two
weeks ago was like no we're trying to
hire VP marketing that's one of your
number one priorities in the marketing
team and you're not doing [__] and I was
like I know because I'm really busy on
the book and my girlfriend he's like
well what do you want to do about it
because that's not moving forward what
you said your priority so I think a lot
of the inputs come back to what I'm
bringing to them as what I believe is
the top problems and he said what are
solutions around it I like can you help
me it he's like yeah actually I'm really
good at it I've hired a lot of VPS he's
been a CMO at big companies and so now
he's spearheading it and I'm not the
bottleneck have you bootstrapped this or
have you taken financing for or
investment for ab okay now you mentioned
a board do you have a board of directors
or an Advisory Board maybe I'm Mish
hearing you no no you're hearing me
correctly so maybe taking a step back
how everyone can do this for themselves
and copy this is think about what's the
weakest part of your business mhm and
think about who what are the five
companies even three companies that
might have the person that you could get
to help you with that mhm and then just
go look up those people in LinkedIn and
then offer them $1,000 to talk to you
for one
hour and that's how we've done it okay
all right so this is this is repeatable
a group of people being paid for their
time to help give you various types of
strategic advice yeah and so you can set
up different retainer agreements you
don't always have to do a thousand could
be more it could be less so we have a
CFO adviser as I said from MailChimp we
have a chief people officer from
dualingo shout out Christine yeah
we have a CR adviser from outdoorsy and
then on the board we compensate them as
well Roger T mooker from indeed because
I'm very good at starting businesses and
I've struggled now that there's more
people rajti runs a 2,000 person
organization yeah and quick question
just to zoom out though yeah yeah
because you have CEO coach but the CEO
coach is really two coaches I have a CEO
coach and a business coach there we go
and then you have marketing coach
marketing coach and then you have the
board so I'm wondering what you get from
the board that you don't get from from
those other things what I have found
most helpful from a board is one
accountability so it's just like here's
what I said I'd do this quarter here's
how I
did and then secondly it's providing an
outside opinion of people that are
thinking differently than me so normally
every time I go to the board meetings
it's like why aren't you growing faster
MH right you're not growing fast enough
and then so it's trying to figure out
what things we should be doing
differently based on the pace that that
personally I would like to run the
company but a lot of times almost all
the coaches are challenging in some
capacity right there they're finding
things that you're not necessarily
thinking about or doing and they bring
that to you even though you may not want
to hear it so let's jump to the grand
finale speaking of accountability so 48
hour challenge yeah let's do it me and
Tim love people taking action for
themselves and I said it earlier the
reason Tim's audience likes Tim is
because you give them things they can
get results for themselves with and
that's why people listen to you among
other things I think that's probably one
of the top so I want people to take
action from this episode if they've made
it this
far I want people to see what they can
do and how they can change your life in
48 hours so this episode comes out
within 48 Hours of launch mhm I want to
see how people can change your life in
either starting a business and if you
already have a business what can you do
in your business in 48 hours and I want
you to leave a comment on Tim's blog and
hash 48 hour challenge in the comment so
that makes sure you're paying attention
so tim. Blog podcast find this episode
you're going to have to do a little work
no aagan it's not that hard put in the
guest name it'll pop right up go to the
newest one leave a comment with #
# 48 hour challenge and what result have
you done in the past 48 Hours what can
you do maybe you have a certain amount
of customers maybe you have one customer
maybe you posted videos ideally here's
what I'm really looking for I'm looking
for the people who are willing to put a
little more extra effort like if they've
taken and you can follow a million
dollar weekend you can do whatever it is
you want see how far you can go in 48
hours and I think there going to be some
people who are like I made $10,000 from
zero What's the price all-inclusive paid
trip one day with me helping you with
your business whether you're starting
whether you're going in Barcelona Spain
this year so it will be delivered within
6 months so I'll fly you out no matter
what country are in the world I'll put
you up in a hotel and we'll have 24
hours together and be able to change
their life if they want to scale their
business if they want to just go to the
beach we can do that if they want to do
cycling but the idea is that if you
limit your time even if you have a
growing business I want people to apply
MH how far can you go in 48 hours mhm
what can you do in the equivalent of a
weekend right so which we all have 48
hours any other recommendations for
people who hear this they're like I'm
excited I want to give it a go
any
other
specifics catalytic ideas anything at
all that you'd like to add to that so
again folks you're going to go to t.
Blog podcast look up no okay again go to
this episode there'll be a blog post for
it and then you're leaving a Blog
comment with hashtag 48 hour challenge
48 hour challenge if you forget that
there going to be probably a lot of
comments so you'll be disqualified if
you don't do that follow the rules any
length limits or anything on this no I
well speaking of it I actually just saw
this on Facebook I printed it out for
you do you remember the Tim fer
obviously remember the Tim Ferris
experiment this was
Cindy so Cindy was someone who followed
our material from when Tim show and we
follow this process that's right and she
changed her life in a very short amount
of time hers was documented not
everyone's was documented I actually got
she sent me a video too amazing oh my
God I got a video for you blast from the
past so she sent a video where sold out
events so 10 years ago I mentored under
Tim Ferris Wing which was the Catalyst
to me stepping into the
entrepreneurialship journey and I have
to say I'm so grateful I did that I'm so
grateful for Tim and Noah because ever
since that day 10 years ago I've been
able to be the leader that I truly want
to be I have my own company now I have
tons of people coming to me for for
support they want to grow and scale
their businesses their companies uh
learning how to build inclusive
communities for their brand and so it's
been very fun um to how to where like my
network has grown like they say your
network is your net worth right and so I
look back at those moments where I work
with Tim and like wow like I have grown
so much like literally and what Tim
teaches has has
lifelong um lifelong benefits because
the way that Tim thinks the way the
concepts around you know the deal
concept d e a l has definitely um been
instilled into my life and so sometimes
I think about when I move into the world
I'm like Hey what how would Tim think
about this cuz I know that like being an
entrepreneur could be really
overwhelming but the thing that I have
learned is that to to keep things very
simplified and results driven um so
anyways I say thank you again to Tim
Ferris it's definitely been a journey
for me sometimes not easy but it's
definitely been a very fulfilling
Journey for myself and um actually yeah
me and my family just got back from
Thailand 2 months ago um been yeah like
I said I've just been living the life so
yeah thank you am but that was someone
that you were able me and you were able
to get started on her entrepreneurship
Journey we probably had roughly you know
one or two days I mean it was not a lot
of time and we had we had a little bit
of time but it was constantly for a TV
show it's like you're stopping you're
starting you're stopping start if you
add up the total number of hours that's
wild that's been super cool same with
Daniel Bliss who was on your blog when
we helped him he was a postal worker he
was actually able to leave to move to
Thailand he was sick so I wasn't able to
get a video of him talking about some of
his results but I think the reality for
everyone out there he asked for some
tactics and tips is yall have your
phones yep you all have the ability to
text call go to people in person see who
you have in your network like Cindy
really like yoga yeah and just by
getting going maybe yoga is not the
million-dollar business and maybe she
doesn't need a million dollar business
but she got that going that's led her
now 10 years later to be able to have
her own business that's wild I'm just
looking at this which I haven't seen and
she sold out her event right so that was
that was the original getting started
the original
and I'll just read this because I think
it's it's worth reading of course wow
well first of all congratulations Cindy
that's so fun so here is just a portion
the trick I learned while mentoring with
Tim and Noah to keep things as simple as
possible focus on the most leverageable
and important thing that would yield the
fastest all caps and best results so
this is after she mentioned she sold out
her event then she goes would I have
sold out this event in 36 hours if I'd
used paid ads no all caps would I have
sold out this event if I'd gone around
to find the nicest most expensive place
to rent no and then in parentheses I got
a free office space instead through a
colleague and brought my disco lights
would I have sold it out if I just sat
in my chair complaining that there
wasn't enough time no would I have sold
out if I reached reached out to people
who didn't know me no it went on and on
and on
and that's amazing that's amazing yeah
that's wild 10 years later still going
good for her it's interesting to think
for the other people who Chang your life
in 48 hours from listening to this one
episode where they'll be in 10 years
totally and it works people have done it
with past appearances people have done
it with writing that you've shared on
the blog and now you've encapsulated it
all after a lot more experimentation
many more businesses a many more years
in the book so the book is million dooll
weekend subtitled the surprisingly
simple way to launch a 7figure business
in 48 hours people can find that on the
website million dooll weekend.com
if people want to interact with you
online do you have any preferred socials
or anything else you'd like to point
people to the website's great mw.com you
can also look me up noan I'm that's
everywhere no aagan everywhere million
weekend.com and again if you you want to
throw your hat in the ring and give the
48 hour challenge a shot listen to this
episode certainly check out the book but
suppose you don't have to check out the
book right you just have to do something
exactly and # 48 hour challenge yep in
the blog comments on the blog post
associated with this episode
Noah good
endurance amazing what ketones will do
for your brain I cheated
but uh thank you for the time always
great to see you great to see
congratulations on all the crazy success
I had no idea that it had grown in the
way that it's grown and what fun amazing
Barcelona life is great yeah is there
anything else you would like to add Noah
before we land the plane I was thinking
how awesome my girlfriend is and one of
the message I was thinking for everyone
out there is just a little bit more
kindness for ourselves mhm if everyone
can just even today like give themselves
a little bit of kindness like you know I
came a few minutes late and I was like
ah you're late what are you doing it's
like it's okay and I think for all of us
just a little bit more kindness and uh
make the world a better place for
ourselves and for everyone else yeah
here here that
is definitely true and also it will just
preserve the gas in the tank too amen
you know life is short but life is also
long in a lot of ways so spare your
calories when you can you know be kind
to recharge yourself and others and
you're going to have off days too there
days when you're going to wake up and
you
know as I've heard said before it's like
if you wake up and you meet an [__]
on a given day that person's an [__]
if you wake up and everyone's an [__]
you might be the [__] and they're
going to be those days so just make a
little bit of extra effort uh Noah thank
you so much this is fantastic check it
out folks million dollar weekend and we
will put links to everything in the show
notes tim. Blog podcast and and until
next
time thanks for tuning in everybody see
you
soon